Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Piss dich, Aldo!
So Leute, ich bin mal außerplanen, wenn sie am Start.
Mal gucken, ob das überhaupt funktioniert. Ah, ich muss die Bitrate hochstellen. Mit der Bitrate kann man nicht spielen, das funktioniert nicht.
Mit der Bitrate kann man nicht spielen.
Das ist Massive Debate.
Mal gucken, ob das Vodafone heute mitmacht. Ich bin ja mal gespannt. Vodafone, please.
Vodafone, please. Zeig mal her.
Stats, stats, okay. Wir probieren das mal aus. Mal gucken. Also ich denke mal, dass ich mindestens am besten 8 Mbit machen sollte, dass das schön flüssig, dass das schön scharf aussieht alles.
Mal gucken, ob das Vodafone mitmacht, Aldo.
NAA im Incoming. Mittlerweile geht's. Es geht halbwegs. Nachdem ich jetzt 4-5 Tage wieder gespielt habe, treffe ich eigentlich wieder ganz okay.
Okay, 8 Mbit. Mal gucken, ob das Scheiß funktioniert. Ich bin gespannt. Das Einzige, was jetzt noch ein bisschen, was jetzt noch ein bisschen failen könnte, ist, dass ich hier auf Window-Modus umgeschaltet habe.
Normalerweise spiele ich Fullscreen. Mal gucken, ob das einen großen Unterschied macht. Keine Ahnung. Theoretisch schon. Praktisch weiß ich nicht.
Event jetzt einfach. Oh, oh, oh. Missed Frames, Leute. MonkaS.
Naja, anscheinend geht's. Liegt. Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder liegt? Laufen ist irgendwas liegt. Ich sag dazu nur.
Mal gucken, ob Vodafone mitmacht. Ich bin mal gespannt. Ich mache mal eine Vorschau an. 360p, das reicht, dass ich sehe, ob es laggt.
Ja, wir spielen jetzt ein paar Waffen frei. Ich habe mir überlegt, warum mache ich das nicht eigentlich mal im Stream. Das haben letztens so viele gesagt, Max, mach das doch im Stream. Warum nicht? Warum nicht?
Mein Standardlayout aktuell ist ja links hier, weil man mal auf Loadouts geht. Das ist ja so meine Standardklasse für nahezu alles M4 Vollausbau. Vielleicht soll ich die Musik ausmachen fürs Spielen gleich.
Ein Stückchen leiser. Pepega Gegner. Ey, das ist übelst krasse Tryhard Action am Start. Das ist so, ey, ich hab ohne Scheiß, Leute, Overwatch ranked ist nichts gewesen gegen das rumgetryharde und rumgeschwitze hier. Ich hab echt selten ein Game gesehen, wo das so krass ist hier.
Vor allem, da kommen die Maps dazu, in denen du dich überhaupt nicht bewegen darfst, ohne dass du dich von irgendeinem Winkel um drei Ecken, wo du nicht richtig siehst, sondern nur irgendwie zwei Pixel vom Kopf rausgucken.
Das hier ist so meine 0815 Klasse aktuell für alles. Das ist ja auch alles OP-mäßige zusammen, der M4, und das Ding ist halt das Schredderteil schlechthin. Oh, Moment, ich glaube, ich muss noch Akimbo ausrüsten hier, da ist besser.
Ah, haben wir schon. Excellent. Ach, Moment, das ist die falsche Klasse. Liederpropper. Akimbo muss da noch rein, WTF. Sonst ist das gar nicht richtig nubsicher für mich.
Nein, nein, nein, Leute. Null W, größer Keck W. Was erzählt ihr mir denn da für Dinger? Das ist ja Fake News. Okay, wir spielen ein bisschen waffenfrei, also sowas hier. Ich wollte mir nämlich noch ein zweites Layout machen.
Also neben meiner 0815 Warzone M4 Klasse wollte ich mir noch hier einen Setup machen und noch einen zweiten Loadout Drop mit der Schneiber. Wo habe ich denn meine Schneiber Klasse? Wo ist die? Warum ist die weg?
Leute, meine Frage an euch, was für eine Schneiber nehmt ihr? Also, ich bin da noch unschlüssig, weil ich will mal ein zweites Loadout machen, was ich dropen lassen kann, wenn man genug Geld hat. Also das Ding oder das Ding?
Ich habe jede Menge Videos gesehen, damit jetzt, in Streams, aber auch damit. Ach, sie hat keinen Kugeltrop, es hat doch alles Kugeltrop, sogar meine M14 hat Kugeltrop. Intervention, was haben wir denn hier?
Was haben wir denn hier? Das ist Stelser Zeug, das brauchen wir nicht. Crazy Knoll. So, wir spielen erstmal hier das frei. Schauen wir mal. Leute, stellt euch darauf ein, dass übelst abgekempt wird jetzt, ich sag's euch.
Was spielen wir? Domination? Also die beste Playlist ist die hier, ne? Also die beste, Moment, das hier, die beste Playlist zum Waffen ranken ist die hier. Das ist aber absolut clusterfuck, ihr werdet es gleich sehen.
Es ist absolut clusterfuck diese Liste, ey. Passt mal auf, das ist der Wahnsinn. Hab ich jetzt eigentlich richtig gesetzt? Guck mal gleich, absolut clusterfuck.
Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich am Anfang, ich mach mal die Musik aus. Wahrscheinlich kommt jetzt gleich am Anfang Rust. Rust, ähm, Domination. Rust, ich sag's, Rust Kill Confirmed. Nein, Alter.
Das ist das Schlimmste. Das ist das Schlimmste. Rust Kill, das wird bloß noch, das wird bloß noch durch Shipment, Shipment Domination getoppt oder so. Das ist das Schlimmste, Leute.
Wir müssen übrigens mal gucken, ob die Lautstärke passt. So, ich, ich, ich, ich rush jetzt mal eine Runde mit meiner MP4 hier rum. Easy. Easy. In your face.
Was ist das? Geile. Ich sag euch, Leute, das ist übelst clusterfuck der Kram. Das ist so geil. Ist aber übelst.
Ist aber übelst. Du weißt überhaupt nicht von wo. Also wie gesagt, das ist hier kein wahnsinnig krasses 30 30 zu 0 Kill Gameplay. Das geht hier gar nicht. Das ist einfach nur Waffenlevel.
MP7 muss ich auch noch leveln. Okay, jetzt stellse wir mal hier oben ein bisschen rum. MP7 muss ich auch noch leveln. Grau muss ich leveln. Oh, fuck. Und ähm, noch ne Schneiber. Schneiber muss ich auch noch leveln.
Oh, was ist da hinten los? Aber den Aim war jetzt ab. Direkt. Das schöne an Hardcore ist tatsächlich, ich hätte nie gedacht, dass ich mal gerne Hardcore spiele. Es geht einfach. What the hell? Es geht einfach schneller. Es geht einfach schneller.
Ja, ist klar. Es geht einfach schneller. Man macht zwar keine krassen Gameplays, aber wenn man Waffen frei spielen will, ist Hardcore tatsächlich viel, viel nicer. Meine Güte, Alter, wieso willst du denn hier hin?
Und ich sag euch, die Map ist halt der clusterfuck schlechter. Guckt's euch an. Du weißt überhaupt nicht, wo du hingucken sollst. Du weißt echt nicht, wo du hingucken sollst.
Aber macht nix. Geht ja nur. Übrigens, wenn ihr irgendwas wissen wollt, ne? Fragenmäßig, wie in jedem Stream einfach reinhauen in den Chat. Ich guck dann rein. Das ist jetzt nicht so, dass... Guckt's euch an. Nicht, dass man sich jetzt hier wahnsinnig konzentrieren müsste. Geht mir ja nur um Unlocks.
Ob da noch einer ist? Wow. Wow. Bonkers. Ich muss hier mal weg. Ich hab Schiss. Am besten ist egg gestehen bleiben. Egg gestehen bleiben ist in Modern Warfare das Mittel der Wahl.
Einfach egg gestehen bleiben. Oh, da kommt was. Das ist so easy. Einfach egg gestehen bleiben. One on one rust quickscope.
What? Ist... Ist... Ist der Dude gerade ernsthaft hinter mir gesporn? Oder war das mein Teammate, was da auf mich geschossen hat? Oh, wir sind Erster. Da bin ich zufrieden. Solange wir Erster sind, ist alles kein Problem mehr.
Ich glaub, wir brauchen noch eins, zwei für Vitorl. Oh nein. Ist leer. Fuck, Alter. Okay, Yolo. Was haben wir denn hier? Übelsreutige Waffen für Hardcore.
Von wo auch immer. So, beste Pose, Leute, zeige ich euch mal, wenn ihr ein bisschen abschimmeln wollt hier. Beste Pose, da könnt ihr hier rauspeaken oder rennen sie euch ins Fadenkreuz. Guckt da hier, da hinten ist schon einer. Der weiß nicht, worauf er sich einlässt. Der krasse Camperkick ist am Start.
Guckt's hier. Sag's euch. Beste, beste Spot. Wenn man einfach nur sitzen will und campen will auf Rust, beste Spot. Guckt euch mal die high detaillierte Schraube oben links an. Beste, beste, beste Sitzspot, beste Camper. Aber ich kann nicht lange campen. Das funktioniert nicht. Ich krieg dann... Ich krieg echt totale Anfälle, wenn ich sitzen muss.
Was? Oben ist einer drauf. Gewinnen wir eigentlich? Ja, wir gewinnen. Okay, gut. Wenigstens gewinnen wir. Da ist links was, ich hab's gesehen. Links hier, da war was, ich hab's. Was ist mit dem los? MonkaS. War da noch was? War da noch einer?
Da war noch einer. Jetzt schon.
Noch einer. Von wegen NA-Aim, Leute. Ich sag's euch, ich hab die letzten Tage wieder geübt. Ist kein NA-Aim mehr angesagt. Aber Skill-Based Matchmaking ist angesagt. Das bedeutet, wenn wir jetzt gut sind, die Runde, dann kriegen wir die absoluten Schwitzgegner des Of Doom.
Das nächste Mal. Fuck, den hab ich nicht gesehen.
Die Schwitzgegner des Of Doom kriegen wir das nächste Mal. Weiß, weiß, weiß.
Und vor allem das geile ist ja das Spawn auf Rust.
Wie? Was soll das? War das mein Kill gewesen? Ich glaub, es geht los.
GP-Gas. Oh, den hab ich schön ver-aimed. Da war's NA-Aim wieder am Start, Leute. Ich geh glaub ich wieder in meine Schimmel-Ecke.
Beste. Oh, oh, teammate, teammate. Ich geh in meine Schimmel-Ecke. Beste hier. Easy, easy win. Easy win.
Wo ist denn hier was? Guck mal, Leute. Es ist Rust. Und noch nicht immer auf Rust bewegt sich was.
Komm, wir gehen jetzt. Wow, wow, wow, wow. Mein teammate. Wie soll man das jetzt sehen so schnell?
Da ist er. Da war er. Jetzt kommt's von hinten bestimmt gleich. Ich sag's euch, Leute. Da wird gesprüht und gebetet.
Gibt's Friendly Fire? Ja, gibt's. Aber die haben's richtig gut gemacht, das Friendly Fire, muss ich sagen.
Das Friendly Fire bringt dich selber um, wenn du zu offensichtlich Team-Kills machst. Find ich eigentlich ziemlich gut gemacht.
Es gibt echt mal ne Sache, die ich loben muss. Wo war da was? What the hell? Habt ihr den gesehen? Jetzt mal ernsthaft?
Ich weiß, der Chat schreibt, ja klar, da war er. Oh ja, krasse C4-Taktik.
Wow, wow. Okay, die müssten, in dem Moment, wo man wegguckt, natürlich alle haben ihn gesehen, logisch.
In dem Moment, wo, what the hell, jetzt wird noch genubt, ich fasse es nicht. Übrigens positive K.D., also generell, das war alles über 1,5.
What the fuck, alles über 1,5 kannst du in dem Spiel eh vergessen. Das sorgt dafür, dass du keine, das geht nicht.
Kann man vergessen, aber das ist auch nicht schlimm. Das ist überhaupt nicht schlimm, ich muss sagen, wenn man sich damit abfindet.
Dass Wins mehr zählen, dass Wins mehr zählen als K.D., ist es vollkommen in Ordnung. Man muss sich bloß und aus, aiaiai. Und außerdem spiele ich das ja eh nicht zum großklassen Hyper-Gameplays machen, sondern zum Waffenanlocken.
Kommt da einer. Ah, im Fuß geschossen. Im Battlefield zählen Wins auch mehr. Ja, ich finde, im Battlefield ja, ja, du hast schon recht.
Allerdings ist es im Battlefield oftmals so, dass ich sag, mein Team geht mir selber so krass auf den Sack, dass ich lieber viele Kills mache. Weil ich hab keinen Bock im Teamplay zu machen im Battlefield, wenn mein Team übelst rumsackt.
Weißt du, wenn du Teamplays machen willst, rennst du in die Gegner rein und dein Team lässt dich da vergammeln. Dann mach ich lieber Kills im Battlefield.
Okay, schön, Achtung, Achtung, schön in die Schimmel-Ecke. Guck, da wäre der nächste gewesen. Aber doch ganz gut platt gemacht. Ja, aber Teamkill, weiß ich. Nee, das sind Confirms, das sind keine Deaths. Ich glaub, weiß gar nicht, ob Deaths überhaupt angezeigt werden in dem Spielmodus.
Doch, ja, 37-21. Wie gesagt, alles über 1-5er KD ist in dem Game eigentlich auf Dauer gar nicht zu halten. Was mir aufgefallen ist, jetzt nachdem ich wieder ein bisschen gespielt habe, ich könnte wetten, dass die ganzen YouTube-Channels, die so ultrakrasses Gaming machen,
Die so ultrakrasses Gameplay machen, was nimmt man eigentlich für die Waffe am besten?
Diese ultrakrasses Gameplay machen, dass das, ich mein beweisen kann ichs nicht, aber ich bin mir sowas von sicher, dass das Reverse boostet ist zum größten Teil.
Ähm, ich hab letztens ein Video geguckt von jemand, der hat Solo, der hat Solo Wars und Trios gespielt.
Solo. Und die Gegner hatten echt keine Hände. Die haben ohne Hände gespielt die Gegner, anders kann ichs mir echt nicht erklären.
Oh, beste Map. Beste Map. Oh, natürlich super Ausgangslage, 3 gegen 5.
Ja, wenn du die K.D. sehen willst in-game, dann kannst du ne... Oh fuck.
Ja, schön von beiden sein. Äh, wenn du die sehen willst von, ja dann...
What? Wie schnell hat der mich denn geaimt? Ah, Pharahspawn, Pharahspawn, Pharahspawn, Massive Pharahspawn.
Ok, der hat mich outplayed.
Ich mag das so. Kill Confirmed ist echt das schlimmste Modus.
Du spawnst rein, wupp, wupp, wupp. Moment, der war da noch, war der noch da hinten eben? Der Dude ist doch noch hier rumgestellt, oder?
Oh nee, den darf ich nicht hoch. Das ist, das ist instant das, wenn man da hoch geht.
Team, move. Ok, jetzt machen wir mal Trick 17.
Wie, da ist nix? What the fuck? Warum ist da nix?
Wer ist da durchgelaufen? Kann doch nicht sein, da ist doch immer was.
Und übrigens, was ihr auch, was man auch sieht in Kill Confirmed, auf, auf, auf deren... What the fuck?
Auf deren Map ist die Runden sind schneller vorbei als... Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Die Runden sind schneller...
What the fuck, was ist das denn? Was ist das denn?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Die Runden sind schneller... What the fuck, was ist das? Hat der mich gestuck mit dem Pfeil?
Die sind schneller vorbei als es irgendwie Zeit, Zeit gibt, ne? Also diese Zeit läuft ab, bevor die Kills erreicht sind.
Das spricht jetzt halt auch für das Schimmel Gameplay.
Was ist das für ein Problem? Da kommt gleich noch einer, ich sag's euch. Oder er kommt da, da hab ich ein Problem.
Oh, fuck. Ok.
Meine Güte, könnt ihr jetzt mal rauskommen? Oh, fuck.
Ja. Aber Hauptsache wir gewinnen. Ich glaub wir gewinnen gar nicht. Ups.
Das war ich nicht.
Ey, woher weiß der Dude immer genau, wenn einer um die Ecke kommt?
Was ist mit dem los? Das ist jetzt schlecht für mich, echt, es sackt. Ich muss hier wieder weg.
Erde mal. Hab ich doch. Hab ich doch. Ey, what?
Ich sag euch doch, wir waren letzte Runde zu gut. Letzte Runde zu gut, das wechselt sich immer ab.
Also mir kann keiner erzählen, dass es hier kein Matchmaking gibt, was das in irgendeiner Art und Weise beschleunigt.
Ey, dieser Dude da unten, was ist denn mit dem los, mit dem weißen Typ?
Der ist immer am Start und guckt gleich in die richtige Richtung.
Ok, da hätt ich nicht sprayen sollen.
Oh, oh, oh, oh. Der kommt da rüber. Ha, der wusste schon wieder. Der wusste schon wieder.
What?
Ok, wir kriegen auf den Sack. Das ist übrigens die beste Map im Game. Nur mal so, angemerkt.
Beste Map im Spiel. Ist ohne Scheiß so. Das ist die, also jetzt nicht hier auf Hardcore-Kill-confirmed, ja.
Aber das ist die einzige Map, die legit, ey, der weiße Typ, der fuckt mich echt ab.
Das ist die einzige Map, die, what the fuck, guckst du mich an, die sinnvolle Wege hat.
Nee, es gibt kein Terminal. Ey, der Wahnsinn, die Rolle ist wirklich voll von Arsch. Der weiße Dude. Jawoll.
Ok, da oben war noch einer, vorhin. Ey, wie krass aimt der mich immer ab?
Es gibt zwei weiße Dudes. Ist er wieder. Wow, was hab ich da jetzt aufgenommen?
Ok, gehen wir mal in die Mitte gucken. Ist das meine Waffe, die ich wieder aufgenommen habe?
Klar, natürlich. Spawn dahinter einem, beste. Oh, Mitte ist gefährlich, Mitte ist echt gefährlich.
Eigentlich muss man den Pro-Run hier machen. Nee, den da. Ja, manchmal geht es gut, aber manchmal ist es halt so krass,
wie da um dich herum gespawnt wird und alles. Da kannst du nichts machen.
Das war klar, dass da einer drin steht. Und was auch, übrigens die Waffe hier, ich muss euch die gleich mal mit Akimbo zeigen.
Das ist die absolute Noob-Schredder-Waffe. Guck mal, ich mach die jetzt mal.
Habt ihr gesehen, wie schnell die killt? Ja, klar. Pass mal auf, pass mal auf, pass mal auf.
Das Ding ist so krass. Überall sitzt einer, meine Fresse.
What? Ich hab's voll vergessen. Ok, ok, die pushen bestimmt von hier rein.
Wir machen jetzt die alt bewährte, ich bleib an der Ecke sitzen und guck Taktik. Ich kann das, ich hab da keinen Bock drauf.
Achtung, jetzt, jetzt. Oh, zu hoch. Oh, Teammate, Grip. Ja, selber Schulter.
Ja, der aimt natürlich wieder ab. Also bei dem Dude, ich weiß echt nicht.
Du kommst doch wirklich um die Ecke. Eiskäuter, mach das nicht. Das ist nichts für schwache Nerven.
Ich guck da auch nur immer rein, ob da nicht irgendwie einer gar so übertriebenes Zeug postet.
Oh, guck mal, wir haben einen neuen Operator. Den gucken wir uns gleich mal an. Wenn ich überhaupt wüsste, wo der Kram überhaupt funktioniert, dass die Menüführung in dem Spiel hier irgendwie, oder? Nee, nee, nee.
Ah, Operator, es gibt sogar einen extra Knopf für. Ja, eh, die font. Game. Ok, fort mit den Videos, ich brauch die Videos von dem Typ nicht. Oh nein, Rust Domination, das wird immer schlimmer.
Rust Domination, Leute. Ok, MP7. Jetzt wird's wieder schlimm. Rust Domination, sag's euch.
Last Nice, Quickscope only.
Links, oh fuck, ich bin hängen geblieben. Ich wollte nämlich gerade raus und den Typ holen, der C, der C einnehmen wollte.
Wie gesagt, gewinnen ist das Beste, gewinnen gibt mehr Bonus. Was macht der da? Gewinnen gibt mehr Bonus und mehr Bonus bringt Waffelevel. Keck weh, der Dude da.
Huge, huge outplayed. Was, was, wo ist hier was? Wo ist hier was? Woah, der wusst's. Wohlgemerkt, ich hab Ghost und Kalplader, der kann ja gar nicht wissen.
Äh, Moment, wo bin ich denn hier gelandet? Jetzt ist schwierig, hier kommst du eigentlich fast nie raus, hier musst du irgendwie durch die Mitte pushen, in der Hoffnung es guckt keiner oben runter.
Was ist hier hängen geblieben? Ja, dass ich diesen Modusspiel will ich hängen geblieben, aber richtig Massive hängen geblieben. Aber es ist der beste Modus zum Waffen unlocken. Ist so.
Comeback, als würd's mich jucken. What the hell? Was zum, was ist hier los? Sind hier gerade alle von mir gespawnt? Moment, der kommt rum, der kommt rum.
Das ist Rust, ja. Woah. Das ist Rust Quickscope Duell gerade.
Oh, da oben war einer. Jetzt muss ich hier mal durch. Wo ist denn der andere Typ? Das Problem ist, du hast keine Ahnung wo jetzt. Ja.
Der kommt jetzt gleich her. Warte, ist der da hoch gerannt? Ich hab's nicht gesehen.
Nee, nee, nee, Kollege, so nicht. Ah, ich dachte da liegt einer. Woah, what the, das, warum schießt mein Teammate auf mich? Der Typ da oben, den müssen wir killen, der geht mir mega auf den Sack.
Oh, da kommt der, was ist das? Care Package? War das ein Care Package oder was war das für ein komischer Drop?
Warum schießt du auf deinen Teammate? Ja, weil er auf mich geschossen hat, ich dachte das ist ein Gegner.
Ah, jetzt schleiden wir hier rein unten. Next. Oh, oh, ich hab was gehört. Ich weiß nicht, ob das Gegner sind.
Einmal runter getropft, instant down. Hardcore, ja, muss ich, weil bester Modus zum Waffen anlocken. Also hier irgendwie krassen Score-Gameplays machst du hier nicht.
Definitiv nicht. Moment, du weißt gar nicht, wo der hin ist. Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal hier, da kommt, da kommt. Aha, what, what, what? Wie, wo ist der hingeh?
Warum sterben die nicht? Zorgst du auch noch eine Runde, Warthorn? Das Problem, ich würde nicht machen, ich hab keinen mit dem ich gerade zusammenspielen kann.
Und Solos in Warthorn ist wirklich Müll. Glaubt ihr Leute, Solos, Warthorn will, wollt ihr nicht spielen. Kann man hier eigentlich seine Waffe auflegen oder so?
What? Ey, du siehst die nicht? Du spielst das nur solo? Ernsthaft? Wie geht das, wie kann man Warthorn solo spielen? Da krieg ich, ich krieg absolut Anfälle.
Was ist denn mit dem da los? Oh, die Runde, ob wir die Runde noch gewinnen? Das wird schwierig, die Gegner drücken ganz schön rein.
Alter. Ey, was ist denn gerade los? Ich krieg hier gar keinen Kill mehr aus. Nächste Runde wird aber wieder besser, ist immer so.
Nächste Runde wird besser. Es ist immer so abwechselnd, abwechselnd so, abwechselnd so. Okay, schauen wir mal kurz hier um die Ecke.
Okay, keine Ahnung was da ist. Oh, oh, ich muss weg. Ich bleib jetzt mal hier stehen, versteck mich in der Hoffnung, ich werde nicht getroffen von der Rakete.
Damn, der hat sich jetzt auch gedacht, BTF, was ist mit dem los? Ich hab übrigens Panik, das fallen ja alle um dich drum herum.
Kämpfen auf Dächer, exakt so. Wir können mal ne Runde Warthorn solo spielen, aber ich zeig euch dann auch warum es halt sackt oder warum ich finde, dass es sackt.
Solo Warthorn wohlgemerkt. Ich kann euch jetzt schon sagen warum ich der Ansicht bin, dass es sackt. Und zwar, du spawnst in Warthorn und sobald du gelootet hast, du hörst nichts mehr.
Du hörst nichts mehr, also wirklich, also es geht, jeder ist direkt, ist direkt in der Ecke und liegt. Das ist das Schlimmste an Warthorn, also an Solo Warthorn. Du spawnst und instant, loadout, loadout, grab die erstbeste Waffe und dann wird hingelegt in Warthorn.
Ja gut, man kann es ja mal wieder probieren mit der APC. Und das ist in Trios halt viel besser. Wir haben heute Morgen eine Runde Trios gespielt, gleich gewonnen, easy.
Oh, fuck. Guckt übrigens, das war jetzt die Teamfire-Geschichte. Wenn du zu offensichtlich den Teammate killst, wow, wenn du zu offensichtlich den Teammate killst, dann stirbst du selbst.
Also ich weiß nicht, wie wir diese Runde gewinnen, aber das kann einzig und allein daran liegen, was macht der Wilson da oben? Das kann einzig und allein daran liegen, dass die Gegner sich nicht für Flaggen interessieren. Was anderes kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Man kriegt hier nix. Man kriegt hier nix. Auf Scoreboard. Probieren wir mal hier hoch zu gehen. Vielleicht kriegen wir da noch was. Wo ist da was?
Hier ist ne Wand. Vielleicht hier? Ist das eine Taktik? Nein, Taktik-Einstieg gibt es ja hier nicht. Ich vergiss es. Gehen wir mal hier hin. Wo ist er denn?
Ach, spawnen die jetzt da hinten oder wie? Gehen wir mal kurz. Nee, jetzt spawnen die nix mehr da hinten. Die sehen übrigens den Schatten. Das ist ziemlich low-brain, dass ich da jetzt runter bin. Das ist eigentlich die beste Pose.
Alter, move dich, Kollege, move dich, move dich, move dich. Oh, ich dachte, wir können ihn spreien, breien. Oh, shit. Ich dachte, wir können ihn spreien, breien.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal die Pistols. Die Pistols sind so krass. Die Pistols sind so krass. Also, man ist besser in dem Spiel-Modus ohne Scheiß mit Pistol Only.
Pistol Only. Mit dem Typ macht, glaube ich, gerade Crossbow-Challenges oder so. Sehen die das, wie ultra krass diese Pistols sind?
Diese Pistols sind so mega krass. Ja, ey, die sind der Wahnsinn. Wir können ja gleich nochmal im normalen Spiel-Modus spielen. Da müsst ihr euch die Pistols mal angucken.
Ah, nice. Wir haben gewonnen. Hab ich gerade gedacht. Mist, ich habe meinen Notepad nicht hier. Weil ich habe mir für Warsound, ich habe es noch nicht auf den anderen Rechner gesyncht, für Warsound habe ich mir so eine To-Do-Liste gemacht.
Oh Gott, da haben wir reingeschissen. So nach dem Motto, an welchen Sachen ich immer verrecke. Und dass ich mir das merke. Was sollte man nicht machen?
Und Solo ist halt das Problem. Ich rush viel zu viel raus. Aber mir macht Solo auch überhaupt keinen Spaß. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich glaube, dass die den Solo-Modus geändert haben.
Weil ich habe auf Reddit was gelesen, dass wohl auch in Solos früher keinen Instant-Respawn gab. Also da habe ich noch nicht gespielt. Wie gesagt, ich spiele ja auch erst mal seit 5 Tagen.
Wie ist so die Video-Qualität? Genau. Die Video-Qualität müsste eigentlich recht gut sein. Aber ich muss mal gucken, ob es irgendwelche Questions oder Technik-Krams-Fragen im Chat gegeben hat.
Übrigens, wenn ich es beim Trüberscrollen sehen soll, müsst ihr echt ein Wupplos dabei schreiben, sonst wird das nichts.
Vollkorn-Mischbrot hat abonniert. Dankeschön. Ich muss unbedingt mal ein Steam-Labs aufmachen. Weil sonst übersehe ich die ganzen Stubs.
Okay, machen wir erst noch ein bisschen MP7. Was? Schon wieder Rust? Ne. Ne. 3 Monate und auch 7 Monate gestubbed. Dankeschön. Poggers. Exzellent.
Also nochmal Rust spiele ich jetzt nicht. Man kann es ja echt übertreiben. Meinung zu Skill-Based-Matchmaking? Offensichtlich.
Und wie gesagt, ich habe es ja am Anfang gesagt, wenn ich mir High-Kill-Gameplays auf YouTube angucke, ich könnte wetten, die sind reverse boosted.
Nicht unbedingt jetzt von den Spielern selbst, weil die sind ja auch mittlerweile big brain, in den Statistiken sieht man das, aber die machen dann quasi einen zweiten Account und joinen sich.
Anders ist das Nohand-Gameplay der Gegner nicht mehr zu erklären in dem Spiel.
Also, ich will nicht sagen alle, ich kenne nicht alle und ich bin jetzt ja bei selbst auch nicht der überkrasse Owner oder so, aber es ist schon auffällig, wenn ich sehe wie jemand Warthorn spielt, solo gegen Trios und die sind alle komplett no brain, no hand.
Alle, ja die komplette Runde. Der spawned im Warehouse quasi und owned Trios solo. Ja, ist klar, ist klar.
Oh, Hardpoint, bester Modus.
Okay, wie komme ich hier rüber? In der Mitte geht eh keiner lang. Alter, die aimen alle wieder ab. Was machst du da?
Okay. What the fuck? Du kannst hier nicht raus. Jetzt haben wir. Der kommt jetzt her. Hardpoint.
Hardpoint. Ey, ich gehe da nicht rein, Leute. Ich gehe da nicht rein in den Hardpoint. Wenn ich in den Hardpoint reingehe, sind es ein Drip.
Wenn spawnen die jetzt hinten? Spawnen die auf der anderen Seite? Fuck, warum renne ich in die Granate rein?
Nichts demliches. Okay, die gehen da hinten. Da kommt bestimmt einer gleich hier hoch. Ich muss erst mal nachladen. War da einer?
Ey, überall, von allen Seiten. Du kannst dich in diesem Spiel auf nichts verlassen. Du kannst dich in diesem Spiel echt auf nichts verlassen.
Außer dass gleich einer in deinem Arsch spawnen, wenn du nicht richtig drauf achtest. Und wirklich, wörtwörtlich.
KappaPride, das spawn dir wirklich direkt hinten drinnen, wenn du nicht hinguckst. Du kannst gar nicht alles checken. Das geht nicht.
Du kannst gar nicht alles checken. Das geht nicht. Wenn du alles checkst, bist du tot.
Okay, die kommen von hier nicht. Wir sind hit. Wir spawnen.
Wo ist denn der Hardpoint? Ach, da. Nice.
Okay. Also, NA-Aim kann mir heute wirklich keiner vorwerfen. Heute ist kein NA-Aim angesagt.
Die kommen jetzt eh von hinten. Lasse? War klar. Aber was willst du machen? Wenn ich mich umdrehe, kommen sie von vorne.
Okay. Die kommen hier rein.
Oh, what the hell
Okay, die sehen meinen laser das ist ziemlich ziemlich kack
Ich wollte einfach nur scoreboard checken ah jetzt gibt es hier ein
Die kommen jetzt hier um die ecke
So war oder auch nicht
Oder auch nicht
Jetzt kommt gleich einer von links ich sag es euch leute es kommt gleich einer von links
Sobald sobald hier links frei ist da gehen wir hier um die ecke
Aufhaken
Manchmal würde ich gerne die killcam sehen manchmal würde ich gerne die killcam sehen wie er das geworfen hat
Komm hoch komm hoch komm hoch
Keck w
Die
Alter wie die wie du hier in jede ecke gehippt wirst
Achtung
Okay, wo ist denn der hardpoint? Ach da hinne
Dahinten im spawnen
Du bist jetzt mal hinter
Du kannst nicht nicht in alles was geht ab 31 kills
What the fuck
Ist doch nicht mal dass es so schlecht gelaufen ist bei mir was ist mit den gegnern
Und immer guckst die fall durch wahnsinnig ja ich habe das mx 300
Oh der ist hart
Der ist hart also der hat und ist wirklich schwierig zu kriegen okay gehen wir mal hier oben durch
Ne der flatt der geht doch hier bestimmt rum jetzt kommt da kommt wie toll der hat mir jetzt noch gefehlt
Der hat mir jetzt noch gefilter wie toll
Geh mal weg da ist einer
Weißt du wie toll es dauernd vorgas
Ja ich bin so perfekt das pre-jump da schon ist klar
Teilweise die jegner ich sag doch es ist jetzt ist das schwerste spiel auf der welt
Ne da gehen wir nicht lang
Wow, kick da auf den sack
Wie hat der Fionn
What the fuck what what what the fuck
Was
Wollt ihr mich komplett verarschen
Was war denn das meine freude
Und
Ach hier ist jetzt nichts oder was bin ich hier rumgeflänkt aber nix da
Ja ich
Komme ich verarscht vor von dem game ansprache ich
Schlecht
Ah
Ja
Ja!
43!
Was geht denn?
Ich glaub, das kannst du runn'n gar nicht machen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Aber ich spiel eh zum anlocken, also insofern...
Who cares?
Spawnsystem ist im Altesis.
Also, Multiplayer-technisch ist da noch deutlich mehr...
Noch deutlich mehr im Eimer als das.
Der kommt hier rum.
Oder auch nicht.
Oder doch.
Andere Seite.
Okay, wir...
Oh nee!
Jetzt bin ich runtergefallen.
Kacknoob.
Natürlich hinter...
Hinter einem, wo sonst?
Aber...
Also ich...
Ich kenne keine Spiele mit so einem...
Mit so einem krass unpredictable...
Also...
Überhaupt...
What the hell?
Spawnsystem.
Das gibt's ja.
Ah, da drüben ist was.
Du bist hier permanent paranoid in dem Spiel.
Hinter mir.
Immer hinter, hinter einem.
Übrigens, äh, wir können gleich mal...
Perfekter Spawn...
Wir können gleich mal in den normalen Spielmodus spielen.
Wir zeigen euch, wie man hier abschimmeln muss, dass es funktioniert.
Der Mega-Abschimmler ist am Start.
Passt mal auf, Clay.
Gleich ist der Abschimmel-Meister da.
Gleich ist der Abschimmel-Meister da, nämlich Silenced MP...
Warum, Team-Mate?
Warum?
Die Gegnerkirche ist mir voll reingejumpt.
Oh, das war NAM.
Das, das war, das war...
Das, das lasse ich mir jetzt gefallen als NAM, ja.
Guckt euch das mal an.
51!
Meine Güte!
Was...
Was zum...
Was ist da los?
51...
Äh...
Okay, da muss ja noch einer drin sein.
Oder auch nicht.
What?
Von hinten.
Du siehst die Gegner nicht echt, Wahnsinn.
Aber ich glaube, MP7 haben wir Clay halbwegs frei gelaffelt.
Also ich weiß jetzt echt nicht...
Warte, kann ich mal spawnen und 5 Meter geradeaus laufen?
Geht das?
Ist das, ist das möglich?
Das ist ja, wenn man eben steht, geht das.
Da war er.
Wir wurden defeated of Doom.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Ähm, was gibt's eigentlich heute?
Über was wird denn heute geflamed?
Über was wird denn heute so geflamed?
Keck, wie größer Lul, wie...
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Okay, wir gucken mal, was als nächstes für einen Spielmodus kommt.
Ich muss da, glaube ich, da was anderes spielen, weil...
Hardcore Moshpit, das ist gerade echt zu viel.
Like good old days.
Mit dem Crossbow of Rust.
Das stimmt nicht.
Den Crossbow gab's im Modern Warfare 2 überhaupt nicht.
Kacknoobs.
Müssen wir ihre Facts straight kriegen.
Hardpoint Shipment.
Okay Leute, wenn ihr gedacht habt, Rust geht nicht mehr schlimmer,
dann wartet mal ab auf Shipment jetzt.
Old Reddit, New Reddit, das ist richtig.
Da hast du voll und ganz recht.
Das müssen wir auch gleich mal machen.
Okay, spielen wir weiter der MP4-Freiheit.
Nicht MP4, was laber ich.
MP7.
Das ist der Clusterfuck, Leute.
Passt auf, ey.
Es ist der absolute Wahnsinn, dieser Spielmodus.
Passt auf, das ist krass.
What the...
Alter.
Shipment ist echt der absolute Wahnsinn.
Ja, das hat er schon abgeaimt, ist klar.
Ey, was hab ich für Gegner?
Die jumpen, die pre-shoten dich schon 5 Kilometer.
Jetzt kommt er mit dem Wheels an, ich fass es nicht.
Jetzt schon.
Guckt euch den Spawn an, habt ihr den Spawn gesehen?
Ey, was ist das denn?
Du spawnst und bist...
Ja gut, es ist Shipment, es ist Shipment.
Also wie gesagt, Shipment ist immer so.
Shipment.
What the fuck, guckt euch mal an, in Spawn.
Shipment, ey, Shipment ist der Clusterfuck.
Schlecht.
What the...
Ich kann jetzt ja nur hier stehen bleiben oder hin aimen.
Shipment, Leute.
Okay, das steht an der Ecke, Shipment.
Guckt euch die Gegner an, wie die uns zerstören.
Die fisten uns weg.
Enjoyable Gameplay, ja, finde ich auch.
Das ist absolut top.
Und ich frage mich, wer...
Oh.
Ich frage mich, wer auf die Cronlorarchitektik gekommen ist.
Ja, wir müssen unbedingt Shipment remakeen.
Shipment ist so eine tolle Map, die muss remake werden.
Ja, top, guckt euch an.
Also wenn das nicht Spaß macht, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Also Leute, ihr habt schlichtweg gerade von Gaming keine Ahnung,
wenn ihr nicht sehen könnt, wie das Spaß macht.
Ja, okay, da habe ich ein bisschen übereinigt.
Also ich finde, es ist offensichtlich, dass es Spaß macht, oder?
Shipment ist super.
Oh, der geht ab, ey.
Wenn du dir nicht direkt hittest, bist du im Arsch.
Einfach random nades.
Oh, fuck.
Alter, was habe ich denn da jetzt aufgenommen?
Übelste Crap-Buffer dafür.
Und der Typ, der sitzt einfach nur da.
Okay, ich sitze jetzt auch mal nur da.
Aber ich kann hier einfach nur da sitzen.
Ich kriege Anfälle, wenn ich einfach nur da sitze.
Guckt hier, zack.
Aber Leute, ihr habt wirklich keine Ahnung,
wenn ihr nicht seht, dass das Spaß macht.
Oder, also die Kills habe ich jetzt eindeutig voll verdient.
Das ist so fail, Alter.
Der Bonus, der Bonus auf dieser Platte.
Passt mal auf, wir machen jetzt Ring 17.
Nein.
Das ist so fail.
Das ist so krass und fail, Scheiße.
Da liegt er.
Okay, komm, holen wir mal jetzt mal die Rinetti raus.
Und Rinetti, oh fuck.
Dein Ping ist hoch, echt?
31, oh fuck.
Wieso?
Geht doch.
Gewinnen wir eigentlich?
Fuck, gewinnen wir?
Nee, nee.
Es ist geil.
Also zum Anlocken ist das wirklich gut.
Der Rest ist einfach nur cancer pur.
Hier übrigens, das ist die beste Camp Posi.
Beste Camp Posi auf Shipman.
Wenn ihr keinen Bock habt, euch zu bewegen, macht es so.
Hier hinten, easy.
Zack, next.
Einfach stehen bleiben und in eine Richtung gucken.
So, best gameplay.
High octane gameplay, easy.
So, so geht's.
Leute, so.
So und nicht anders.
So hat der Typ auch nach 3 Sekunden seinen Wilson gekriegt.
Komm, noch besser ist übrigens, wenn man das hier aufstürzt.
Einfach hier stehen bleiben, geradeaus gucken.
Fertig.
Äh, okay.
Oder am Erst.
Doppelte Airstrike am gleichen Erst.
Alter.
Shipman, Shipman, please.
Please, Shipman, geh vorbei.
Geh vorbei.
Geh vorbei, Shipman, please.
Ich spawn hinter den Gegnern, perfekt.
Aha, okay, er ist hinter mir gespotten.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Moment, haben die Chopper?
Haben die jetzt einen Chopper am...
Nice spawn.
Einfach mal hier bleiben, easy.
Ich geh da nicht raus.
Guckt euch an, warum soll ich da rausgehen?
Das sah vielleicht ein C4 aus, aber das war's.
Ja, easy.
Next.
Das ist so fein.
Was haben die sich gedacht bei...
Was haben die sich bei Infinity Ward gedacht?
Oh ja, lass Shipman rebaken.
Oh, wir haben gewonnen?
Wie haben wir das gemacht?
Okay, wir gucken die nächste Map und wenn nicht, muss ich was anderes spielen.
Ich muss was anderes spielen.
Wir können echt einen Solo Warsorn spielen, aber wie gesagt, Solo Warsorn ist ziemlicher Crap, finde ich.
Hab ich euch schon mal eine ultra-nice... ich wurde zur Hälfte gecarried, Warsorn-Stats gezeigt.
Was hier, Wins.
Guck euch mal an, 6 Wins, 11 Top 10 und das Ganze mit nur 91 Kills und 36 Stouts.
Da zeichnet sich Crank auf... ne, ne, ne.
Wir probieren's nochmal, wir probieren's nochmal.
Was hältst du vom Warsorn-Money-Mode? Hab ich noch nie gespielt.
Ohne Skill-Base-Batchmaking macht jede zweite Runde Spaß mit Skill-Base-Batchmaking macht jede zehnte Runde Spaß.
Oder sag mal so, mit Skill-Base-Batchmaking macht fast keine Runde so richtig Spaß.
Kennst du schon die App Cellmapper? Ne.
Was du Maps-Mobilfunk machst, ist das für die 5G-Hater.
Was haben wir Cranked?
Oh Gott, Cranked.
Die Leute sind teilweise zu krass. Der pre-jumpt einen um die Ecke und hittet.
Teilweise sind die echt zu krass.
Oh, das war ein Teammate. Ist ja gut. Übrigens, ich hab den Chat aus Versehen ausgeplandet.
Ich muss den Chat mal wieder einplatten. Oh, Moment. Chat, seh euch nicht.
Der Q-Chat ist weg.
Wo ist denn der Typ? Wo ist der denn hier oben?
Oh, ne. Ich hab genug Rust, Leute. Ich hab genug Rust.
Das reicht mir.
Genug Rust.
Wie die pre-aimt um die Ecke laufen, Alter. Wie geht das denn?
Ich mein, woher wissen die das immer?
Na gut, den hätt ich sehen können. Was kommt nach dem Crank-Time, wenn man stirbt?
Wow, das hat ernsthaft nicht gereicht.
Okay, ich hab jetzt auch mal versucht, krasse Pre-Shoot-Action zu machen.
Es hat auch ein bisschen funktioniert. Oh, Kack-Posi, Kack-Posi.
Hier kommt man nicht richtig raus, außer durch die Mitte.
Was ist da links? War da was?
Tatsächlich.
Gucken wir mal die Ecke. Der ist oben. Der ist oben.
Achtung, ich wollt grad rauf-C4'en. Das wär nice gewesen, hätte ich hier um-C4'et oben.
Ja, es gibt jetzt Crank, aber auf Rust ist es halt...
Guckt's euch an. Nee, ich hab keinen Bock auf dieses Rumgesitze, Alter. Das ist mir grad zu anstrengend.
Ich würd ja gerne Shoot-House spielen. Das Problem ist, es gibt keine Shoot-House-Playlist.
Shoot-House ist die beste Map. Der Rest ist, weiß nicht, irgendwie doof.
Was ich auch ganz gerne spiel, ist das da. Problem dabei ist, es gibt eigentlich kaum gescheite Maps.
Guckt euch das mal an. Hab ich das Richtige gesetzt?
Es gibt eigentlich kaum gescheite... Also, gut, warum... Ich mein, es gibt in diesem Spiel fast nicht an gescheiten Maps,
egal in welchem Spiel-Modus.
So, eigentlich wollt ich ja gar keine MP7-Level, sondern das Ding hier.
Und so blöds ist, die Hardcore-Playlist ist echt die beste für Waffenlevel.
Was ich ja echt feiern würde, die haben ja schon Wacons, wie man das spricht, Crash, drinnen und noch irgendeine Map.
Oh nee, hier wird geschlichen. Ich seh's schon, Leute. Oh, es wird Hardcore-gestalzt.
Guckt euch an, es wird Hardcore-gestalzt.
Das ist ja fast noch schlimmer.
Wie in das andere Garage. Hier wird Hardcore-gestalzt.
Whoa, dodged.
Da ist er.
Was ist nächstes?
Okay, wo kommen die jetzt? Ich hab keinen Schimmer von der Map.
Und in jedem Fenster sitzt einer.
Alter, was ist das für ein Game? Was ist das für ein Game? Das ist doch kein Call of Duty mehr.
Ernsthaft, Leute. Das ist doch lächerlich.
So ein krasses Rumgesitzer, ey. Meine Güte.
Wer hat sich bei Infinity Ward gedacht? Ja, genau so wünschen sich die Leute Call of Duty.
So muss es sein. So ist es gut.
Ich kann mich nicht bewegen. Wenn ich hier rausgehe, Leute, dann bin ich tot.
Okay, da hätt ich nicht repeaken sollen. Aber es ist hart. So fehlend.
Und außerdem, wenn man in eine Runde reingeworfen wird, ist es auch dumm. Aber trotzdem, please.
Guck, eigentlich... Jetzt sind sie hinter einem, ey.
Nee, die sind da multiplayer. Moment, Leute.
Ich wollt Sachen anlocken, fällt mir gerade ein. Warum spiel ich meine gute Klasse?
Okay, wir sind in ein scheiß Game reingejohnt.
Das ist quasi so wie In Search and See. Ja, echt so.
Am besten geht eigentlich immer noch...
Wir spielen das noch mal.
Also, ich bin echt hin und hergerissen, welchen Spielmodus ich am wenigsten...
Ich weiß, dass ich eine Hammer Map erwischt hab.
Ich bin immer noch hin und hergerissen, welchen Spielmodus ich am wenigsten schlecht finde.
Das heißt schon was, ja.
Capture the Flag spielt keine. Kill confirmed, Hardpoint.
Am besten, also am meisten Spaß, wenn man eine halbwegs gescheite Map hat, macht eigentlich immer noch Domination.
Und das 10v10 finde ich auch nicht schlecht, solange es eine gescheite Map gibt.
Das Problem ist halt, dass 80% der Maps ziemlich der Dreck sind.
Das ist halt doof, ja.
Und was ich auch nicht verstehe ist, warum kann man keine Maps voten?
Ich meine, wenn man 80% Crap Maps hat, und die könnten ja einfach eine Umfrage machen.
So, was sind eure Lieblingsmaps?
Da kommt dann raus Gunrunner, Shoot House, vielleicht Crash oder die alten Remake Maps oder so.
Also, da gibt es ja nicht so viele.
So, und dann könnte man sagen, ok, dann lassen wir doch wenigstens die Leute, was war denn das nochmal für eine Map,
dann können wir wenigstens sagen, ok, dann lassen wir die Leute voten, dass sie wenigstens die Maps spielen können, wie sie wollen.
Oh, das ist das Ding. Die Map sagt übrigens auch.
By the way, wer hätte das gedacht?
Ok, wir sitzen ein bisschen.
Huge.
Eine nice Camp Simulation.
Ist da ein VTOL oben?
Sehe ich das richtig?
Sehr gute, sehr gute Runde wieder.
Monka, Achtung.
Tja, Kollege.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt in diesem Haus sitzen bleiben, weil das Camping Warfare ist.
Man kann sich hier nicht einfach bewegen.
Was meint ihr denn, was passiert, wenn ich mich hier bewege?
Wenn ihr das klappt?
Muss hier sitzen bleiben.
Man muss hier sitzen bleiben.
Wenn man hier nicht sitzen bleibt.
Guck, easy. Kaum Camp ist der VTOL am Start.
Das ist so lächerlicher Kram.
Bleib jetzt hier liegen. Easy.
Bleib jetzt hier liegen.
Next.
Jetzt split.
Triple Nuke.
So, easy. Ich habe übrigens Hand von der Tastatur.
Bleib einfach nur hier liegen.
Bam, VTOL.
Gucken wir mal auf den Heartbeat Sensor.
Da kommt...
Fuck.
Chopper Gunner.
Es ist so ein lächerliches Campspiel.
Es ist so ein abgefucktes Campspiel.
Schlägt mich jetzt hier in die Ecke, Chopper Gunner.
Jetzt sitzen sie natürlich alle drinnen.
So ein Campspiel, Alter.
Gott, ich lebe noch. Ich lebe noch.
Oder bleibe ich hier liegen? Achtung, easy.
Weiter geht's.
High Octane Gameplay. So ist das gut, Leute. Perfekt, easy.
Das ist super gemütlich, ja?
Ah, Teamate.
Das Krampf, Alter. Was ein Fail-Spiel.
Der kommt gleich hier rein. Wie sag's euch? Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
Oh, nee. Nee, der kommt oben.
Nee, der kommt oben. Was denn jetzt?
Nein, nein. Max, nicht bewegen. Nicht bewegen.
Nicht bewegen. Wenn ich bewege, ist direkt da unten wieder.
So. Achtung, Achtung. Gleich der nächste. Gleich der nächste.
Warum... Warum kriegt man mit so einer bescheuerten Taktik
einen Chopper-Gunner?
Was ist das?
Das ist so fail. Das ist so fail, das Spiel.
Ich lese sogar ein Chat nebenbei jetzt.
Nee, Krug, Dankeschön.
Oh, Cruise-Messel. Nee, Kollege, du erwischst mich auch mit der Cruise-Messel nicht.
Okay, gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal.
Oh, jetzt haben wir re-peaked. Wenn wir re-peaken, sterben wir.
Wir, wir campen einfach weiter, easy.
Easy, next.
Die ganze Game mit dem Haus drin. Perfekt, perfekt.
Ja, du hast gedacht, du kannst mich flenken.
Zack, easy. 24-1 oder so.
Was ein Capspiel, Alter.
1000 IQ, aber richtig.
Also, ich würde sagen, Leute, ohne Scheiß,
für dieses absolut high-octane, high-skilled Gameplay
müsste es ja schon mal ein paar Prime-Subs geben.
Das war ja nun wirklich absolute Pleading Edge, never seen before, beste.
24-0, Leute, in your face.
Wo habt ihr das schon mal gesehen?
Fast, fast nuke.
Es ist so, es ist so, ich nehme das gar nicht auf,
ich kann das gar nicht hochladen.
Okay, zumindest weiß ich schon, wo ich direkt mitten muss, je nach Map.
Gucken, was für eine Map gleich kommt.
Ach so, Chat, ich wollte ja mal gucken, ob ich was übersehen habe.
Habe ich Subs übersehen? Ich hoffe nicht.
Nope.
Ah, Sebaru, für Leute, die wissen wollen, wie gut die Mobilfunkabdeckung ist.
Ach so, verstehe. Gut, ich habe auch nicht gedacht,
dass es für die 5G-Verschwörer ist, aber man weiß ja nicht.
Ich meine, es ist ja logisch, Corona kommt aus China
und China hat gute 5G-Ausbau, dann muss es ja logischerweise an 5G liegen.
Da sind wir uns ja mittlerweile einig, es ist ja allgemein bekannt.
Da hast du recht, Search and Destroy ist der Modus, der mir noch
vom normalen Multiplayer mit ein paar Leuten am meisten Spaß macht.
Die Map ist übrigens auch übelst räudig, ich sage euch nochmal.
Okay, hier können wir vielleicht die MP7 frei spielen.
Hier können wir vielleicht ein bisschen MP7 frei spielen.
Bill Gates ist schuld. Bill Gates finanziert bestimmt 5G-Masten in China.
Sixhead.
Was haben wir denn bereits für ein Modus? Ah, Headquarters.
Headquarters. Headquarters.
Die sprechen das immer so geil aus, die Voice Actors.
Die sagen nicht Headquarters. Headquarters.
Ups, äh, ja.
Hier, das ist der Inbegriff des Modern Warfare Multiplayers, Leute.
Wow.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, gut.
Ah, knapp.
Wir, wir respawnen. Warum ist...
Ach, weil es Headquarters sind, ich kack nur.
What the hell? Okay, ich weiß überhaupt nicht woher.
Der Ultraskiller. Oh, das ist Headquarters, Leute, das wird spannend.
Kaum hat er sich bewegt, war er tot. Richtig, richtig.
Das ist das Problem beim Multiplayer.
Naja, ähm, aber ich muss sagen, wenn man das Spiel zum Waffenlevel, geht das.
Übrigens, das Pro-Movement ist ja der hier.
Hm, Monka.
Giga. Wow.
Jetzt wäre es, wäre es jetzt mal Hardcore gewesen.
Alter, ist ja gut. Regt euch ab.
Ganz ein Tryhard, geh schnell, ey.
Meine Güte, ey. Du musst dich ja permanent auf Anschlag spielen, dass du was auf die Reihe kriegst.
Kommt die hierher?
Achtung, Stealth Mode activated.
Stealth Mode, Stealth Mode.
Nee, hier ist nichts.
Warum sind da gerade alle auf einmal verreckt?
Das war ziemlich, ziemlich knapp. Ziemlich close.
Ok, wo kommen die überhaupt hin? Ah, Leute, ich hab Spot gefunden.
Excellent, wir können weiter sitzen.
Weitere, weiterer Schimmelspot gefunden. Huge.
Jetzt kommen sie bestimmt von hinten.
Leute, wie ist denn das bei Headquarters? Gibt's da einen Spawn?
Jedes Team hat nur einen Spawn oder wechselt das?
Weil ich hab echt Paranoia in dem Game, dass du laufend von der Seite geaimt wirst.
Laufend von der Seite kriegst du irgendwas ab, da oben.
Fuck.
Ah, den hätt ich nicht öfters spielen sollen.
Übrigens, ich hab das ganze drei Kills schon geschafft hier.
Nehmen wir mal.
Das ist übrigens Instant Death hier.
Kann er das mal, kann er mal sterben vielleicht?
Aufpieken, Kollege, piek.
What the hell?
Da geh ich gar nicht hin. Wenn ich dahingehe, bin ich auch tot.
Ah, wie soll man dieses Spiel spielen?
Hier auch.
Okay, wie lauf ich denn jetzt?
Wie lauf ich? Okay, geh mal vor, Kollege, du willst erst sterben.
Excellent.
Okay, flank, flank action.
Oh, ich kann noch.
Wo sind sie überhaupt?
Okay, ich nehme mal mit ein.
Besser. Entweder sterben oder Gegner nicht finden.
Wechsel, ah, okay.
Ich hab da irgendwas gesehen.
Ah, hit.
Okay, hingeguckt, Seite weg, jawoll.
Ich glaub, der VTOL suckt hier, oder?
Moment, hier gehts gar nicht. Fuck, Alter, wie sind die Laufwege auf der Map?
Ach nee, jetzt ist man hier oben.
Respawn disabled, okay.
Ich glaub, ich spiel, ich bin, hab keine Ahnung von den Quarters.
Ich glaub, so macht man das nicht, oder?
Alter, der Dude.
Wo sind denn die Gegner?
Okay, aus der Hüfte so weit schießen kann man nicht.
Hat das, ja, hat das, hat das, hat nukes.
Ach, hier sind wir im Headquarter drin, okay.
Okay, wir machen jetzt big brain play.
Big brain play.
Irgendwie ist die Waffe kacke. Wir probieren mal, wir probieren mal die andere aus dafür.
Die muss ich eher anlocken.
Das ist eigentlich der Grund, warum ich den Stream übrigens gestartet hab, weil ich mir die Waffe anlocken will.
Respawn disabled, okay.
Okay, wir schimmeln hier oben jetzt, easy.
Easy up, Camp Horn.
Richtig big brain, ja.
Meine Güte, ist das anstrengend.
Ich überleg mir grad, wie man Headquarters spielt.
Das wollte ich gar nicht, ich wollte, by the way, das da.
Steht man eher am Headquarter rum, pusht man in die Gegner, flankt.
Wie Headquarters gespielt, großartig.
Und vor allem, wo um alles in der Welt kommt auf der Map hier irgendwas her?
What?
Okay, ich blicke, ich blicke legit nicht durch.
Ich blicke legit nicht durch gerade.
Okay, kann man hier irgendwie hoch?
Wo ist hier was?
Ich glaub, ich bin da zu small brained für.
Okay, die Waffe ist aber ohne Upgrades echt kacke.
Ich hab Stims, dann nehm ich mir keine Stims.
Okay, pushen wir mal rum.
Da ist nix mehr, oder?
Come on.
Okay.
Wo kommen die jetzt her?
Hier?
Nee, hier.
Hier, die Seite.
Oder da?
Ich blicke es nicht.
Okay, wir pushen hier anscheinend durch, bis es aussieht.
Porgas.
Ah.
Achtung, easy, easy, easy, easy.
Ah nee, die sind weiter gepusht.
Ich wusste, dass du von hinten kommst, Kollege, so nicht.
Oh, N8, richtig N8.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Pass auf, der kommt hier gleich.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, ein VTOL.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Achtung, Achtung, Leute.
Easy, easy, easy.
Ach, shit.
Doch, die werden wir jetzt wegrehen, netti.
Aber habt ihr das wieder gesehen?
Was hat zum Erfolg geführt?
Ecken, Ecken campen hat zum Erfolg geführt.
Okay, ich glaube, so langsam kriege ich raus über den Kramsteel.
HQ?
Wo ist das überhaupt?
Ah, hier jetzt, okay.
Oh.
Sieht übel aus wie Tarkov, ma'am, ja, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das eigentlich ein
fast paced Shooter immer war.
Und aktuell ist da irgendwie wenig fast paced.
Achtung, bam.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Guck mal, mein VTOL ist tot, oder?
Nee, der kommt gerade, er ist reingeflogen.
Okay, ich glaube, das muss man mit Hauptquartier anders machen.
Man darf keine übelste Flank-Action machen und man darf auch nicht direkt auf dem Hauptquartier
stehen.
Man muss schauen, dass man irgendwie in der Nähe vom Hauptquartier rumstellt.
Und dann das Übliche macht, wie man halt in Modern Warfare macht, die Sachen ab-aimen.
Achtung, Achtung, hier, big, big.
Ach, das ist gar kein Gegner.
Hier.
Nice Camp-Action, easy.
Jawoll.
Next.
Das ist ja ein tolles Spiel.
Oh, wie toll.
Oh, HQ.
Nee, Moment, da gehen wir am besten hier rüber, oder?
Die schnellsten werden hier oben durch.
Okay, hier ist doch bestimmt irgendwas.
Was?
Zum Geier, ey.
Immer aus der anderen Richtung.
Okay, machen wir das hier.
Mehr, mehr Money.
Und jetzt habe ich echt keine Ahnung, in welche Richtung ich gucken muss.
Hier?
Oh, da kommt was.
Ich finde es krass, wie die schon immer ab-aimen, alles.
Na gut, ich habe Re-Peek.
Re-Peeken ist da tot in dem Spiel.
Das System muss man sich echt merken.
Re-Peeken ist da tot.
Wenn die die schon aimen, ist vorbei.
Oder so.
Aber danach haben wir schöne Aufsätze anlockt.
Whoa.
Achtung.
Ach.
Ich weiß nicht so wirklich, wo hier was abgeht.
Hier, Head-Glitch.
Head-Glitch, Head-Glitch, beste.
Head-Glitch-Posi.
Hier, stehenbleiben, stehenbleiben.
Oh, nee.
Es spawnen sie auf der anderen Seite.
Spielmodus Small Brain habe ich dafür.
Zu Small Brain.
What the fuck?
Ah, du bist überall abge-aimt.
Wie toll in einer Halle ist High IQ, ja.
What?
Alter, was zum...
Wo muss man hier schauen?
Ah, nee.
Okay, wir bleiben jetzt mal hier oben sitzen und gucken mal, ob wir...
Spielt...
By the way, spielt die Waffe jemand im Multiplayer?
Was sind da gute Set-Ups?
Ich wollte hier nämlich mal anloggen, weil ich habe irgendein Video gesehen mit einem
Loadout-Vorschlag, das sah mega nice aus.
Ja, easy.
Boah, zum Glück ist der Kram vorbei, äh.
Zum Glück ist der Kram vorbei.
So.
Also, ich wollte ja gucken, wo geflammt wird.
Um die Grau.
Man kriegt den OP-Lauf erst ab 35, das ist kein Problem.
Ich kann Waffenexp boosten.
Mein aktuelles Set-Up ist M4 und Renetti und M4 mit dem Monolithic Suppressor, dem...
Boah, ich kann immer gerade reingucken.
Äh, das da.
Monolithic Suppressor, weil der als einzige Sound-Suppression und Damage-Range hat, was
eigentlich ziemlich cool ist und der Rest ist nicht so, nicht so entscheidend.
Ähm, den Stock, weil Velocity.
Dann den Laser, weil warum nicht?
Oh.
Besser.
Aiming Stability ist nie verkehrt.
ADS-Speed-Shot auch nicht.
60 Schuss, weil...
Alter, der Taser!
BTF, huge subscription.
Exzellent.
Dankeschön.
High IQ-Subscription, dankeschön.
Ähm, und unten drunter hier den Kommando-Grip für, ähm, besseres Aiming.
Spielt sich eigentlich echt nice.
Habt ihr doch gerade gesehen, wie gut das Set-Up ist?
24-0 Chopper-Gunner, easy.
Bestes Set-Up, um auf der Treppe zu liegen.
Oh Mist, ich hab vergessen, den XP-Boost zu machen.
Nein!
Oh, und wieder die Sucker-Map, Leute, wieder die Sucker-Map.
Wieder die Sucker-Map.
Sucker-Bus.
Okay, wir wissen ja, wovon wir hinmüssen.
Nee, das machen wir nicht, nochmal.
Ich mein, so nice ein Low Absolute Brain, der 24-0-Chopper-Gunner ist, aber das kann
ich nicht machen, das kann ich nicht jedes Mal machen.
Aber was auch eine ganz gute Pose ist, die ich gesehen hab, wenn ich jetzt hier überlebe,
durchzukommen, ist hier oben drin.
Hier ist es auch ganz nice, hier kann man nämlich auch schön, schön glitchen.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ist klar, ist klar.
Und danach spielen wir echt mal ne Runde Warzone-Solos.
Und könnt ihr mich abscheißen sehen, den Solos.
Okay, wir sliden jetzt hier mal rein.
Wow!
Monka!
Oh, wir sind wieder in unserem Lieblingshaus gelandet.
Leute, habt ihr gesehen?
Wir sind wieder in unserem Lieblingshaus.
Es ist, ja, ist da immer, es ist, es ist, es ist, es ist.
Ah, shit.
Findest du es toll, dass das Game immersive sein soll?
Oh ja, Immersive-Camp-Simulator ist es.
Wow!
Okay, ich weiß gar nicht woher.
Der Immersive, der Immersive, ich sitze im Fenster und gucke aus dem Fenster und bewege
mich nicht, Simulator, ist das.
Ich meine, what the fuck, Alter?
Oh, ich weiß gar nicht, wo du hin sollst.
Was richtig nice wäre, wenn die ne Playlist machen mit den beliebtesten fünf Maps, dann
könnte man das halbwegs spielen, glaube ich.
Alter, da oben ist er.
Achtung, mal Heartbeat rausstellen.
So ein Gesitze, Alter, so ein Gesitze.
Okay, Flank, mal rechts rum.
Okay, links, rechts, rechts, links, oben, unten, wo ist da was?
Man weiß es nicht.
Die Maps sind, du musst, du hast 30 Milliarden Mal mehr Winkel als auf CS-Maps.
Oh, guck mal, da kommt ein Loadout, easy, lull.
Mal kurz hier einen abcampen, ob der da vorbei läuft.
Oh, nee.
Oh, fuck, da kommen 30 Milliarden Gegner.
Habt ihr es gesehen, wie da einfach fünf Gegner vor der Tür gestanden haben?
Hätte ich mal zwei Sekunden mit dem C4 gewartet.
Wo bin ich denn überhaupt hier?
Du siehst hier auch nichts, guckt es euch mal an.
What the fuck, Alter?
Okay, stellst du mir mal den Heartbeat-Sensor?
Ich sehe nichts.
Heartbeat-Sensor nochmal stellzen, wieder nichts.
Okay, Leute, wir müssen jetzt hier sitzen bleiben kurz.
Wir müssen kurz hier sitzen bleiben.
Die sind ja hier vorne.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, mein Team-Mate pusht dann.
Wisst ihr, wie gut das geht, wenn man weiß, wo die Gegner sind?
Okay, Yolo.
Jaja, kriegt mich ab.
Habt ihr den gesehen?
Ich, by the way, nicht.
Oh, eine Wilson.
Ich bin geflasht.
Ich konnte die Maus nicht mehr bewegen.
Keck W.
Gibt es?
Achtung.
Kacknoobs.
Endlich mal wieder ein paar Bobs, die gebashed werden wollen.
Guckt es euch an.
Natürlich von hinten, von wo sonst.
Du kannst die Maus nicht schneller bewegen, wenn du geflasht bist.
Wenn du gestunt bist, nicht wenn du geflasht bist.
Oh, sehr fairer Spawn, sehr fairer Spawn-Spiel.
Excellent Spawn.
Direkt hinter dem Gegner.
Sehr fair.
Okay, gucken wir mal an die Ecke.
Sagt mal, geht euch das auch so?
Es achtet keiner auf den Laser.
Das steht zwar so fest da, Achtung der Laser.
Die Gegner sehen den Laser.
Aber keiner interessiert sich für den Laser.
Sind unter mir Gegner?
Sind das Teammates?
Okay, man sieht nichts.
Okay, wir pushen mal links rum.
Aber da werden wir wahrscheinlich gebashed jetzt.
Hartpiz sagt nichts da.
Nächster Hartpiz sagt auch nichts da.
Okay.
Ja.
Okay, wir müssen jetzt mal die Tür zu machen.
What?
Shotgun.
Alter, halbe Stunde geflenkt um die Gegner.
Gute Posi gehabt und dann erst mal geschotgunnt werden.
Aber echt, Leute, echt.
Das kann ich mir nicht erklären.
Okay, wir machen das gleich noch mal.
Hartpiz Sensor stellt nichts da.
Am Fenster ist einer, ich habe es aber schießen gehört.
Oder auch nicht.
Okay, wir beeilen uns.
Die Map ist hier hinten so groß wie Groupie Black Ops 1 Maps insgesamt.
Oh, Tür zu.
Modern Campfare, aber hart, echt hart.
Okay, jetzt ist hier natürlich nichts mehr.
Okay, dann gehen wir raus.
Dann nehmen wir unsere komische Route wieder auf der rechten Seite.
Von rechts könnte ja was kommen jetzt eigentlich, oder da oben?
Wo sind denn überhaupt Gegner?
Ich meine, fuck.
Was ist das für eine riesen Map?
Okay.
Oh, guck mal, habe ich Final Kill?
Habe ich Final Kill?
Achtung, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Final Kill?
So richtig schön NA-aimt am Sliding.
Oh, kein Final Kill.
Kein Final Kill.
Time Limit erreicht, ja?
Überlegt euch mal, ein Kill konformt, was das Time Limit erreicht.
Das ist wirklich...
Ich meine, es muss dir noch aufgefallen sein, dass das irgendwie nicht so der normale Spielfluss ist, wenn Kill konformt, nach 10 Minuten keine 75 Punkte hat, oder?
Oder hat sich dabei bei Infinity Ward...
Na gut, Infinity Ward und Blizzard, also Activision und Blizzard, die sind ja mittlerweile relativ dicke.
Und Blizzard hat ja quasi vorgemacht, wie verkackt man es kann mit Maps in Overwatch.
Oder hat sich Infinity Ward gedacht, ey, Blizzard Map Designer, zeig uns doch mal, wie es geht.
Alter, Tanser, hast du zu viel Geld?
Was ist mit dir los?
Zehn Stück, dankeschön.
Huge Sub.
Wer hat denn was gekriegt hier?
Das ist ja schon hier.
Hyper, Hyper Subscriber.
Big Brain.
Wer hat was gekriegt?
Kriner's Keepers, Carl Virux, oder Viro wahrscheinlich, weil das ja bestimmt französisch ist.
Ey, was spielen wir denn eigentlich für eine Map?
Och net, schon wieder!
Please, nicht nochmal!
Ähm...
Captain Peng, The Re5 Ads, Sola von Astora, Das Totale Trivau, Manuel98, Rob, LM, AncientStarmag.
Ja, dankeschön für die ganzen Subs.
Krasser Schiff.
Massive.
Um nicht zu sagen, Hoggers.
Was, was, was, was hat mich da?
Ja, ist gut.
Warum steht da hinten einer?
Was soll das?
Chat, habt ihr dem erlaubt da zu stehen?
Ich finde, der sollte instant geblockt werden.
Instant Ban, dass er da gestanden hat.
Achtung!
Ja, fuck!
Wir hatten die gleiche Idee!
Aber er war noch hinter dem Pfalz.
Moment, wo sind wir überhaupt?
Ah, Camp House, perfekt.
Gegner, wo sind die Gegner?
Warum ist das so ein komisch, merkwürdiges Game, wo man nie weiß, wo was ist?
Und meistens sind sie hinter einem.
Ah, Moment, spielen wir...
Ach, wir spielen Headquarter.
Das muss einem ja auch mal einer sagen.
Das muss einem ja auch mal einer sagen, dass wir Headquarter spielen.
MonkaS.
Okay, alle Gegner tot.
Wo spawnen die denn jetzt?
Hinten?
Ha!
Get rekt!
Oh, fuck!
War das ein Krachspiel, aber echt...
Also der Multiplayer ist wirklich mega suckig.
Wo kommt man eigentlich hier lang?
Ich war ja noch nicht in jedem Haus auf der Map, das muss ich jetzt hier gleich mal...
Gerade mal angucken, wie das geht.
Wo sind... was zum Teufel, wo sind wir denn hier?
Wo sind wir denn hier gel...
Wow!
Sind wir im Gegner spawnen oder sowas?
Äh...
House, House layout.
Hier ist auch noch mal eine riesengroße Map.
Yeah, Carl!
Im Multiplayer...
Deswegen spiele ich ja Multiplayer, weil man schnell die Waffen löffelt.
Muss ein bisschen was killen, aber was sich gerade als sehr schwierig rausstellt.
Weil ich nicht weit...
Hä?
So geht's.
Kann man hier aufs Dach irgendwie...
Ich hab dich gesehen, Kollege.
So nicht, so nicht, so nicht.
Also sollte...
What the hell?
Sollte Headquarters dazu führen, dass man halbwegs Predictables Spawns kriegt, dann werde ich auch ein bisschen mehr Headquarters spielen.
Weil das ist ja das Schlimmste an dem Modus, bzw. an dem Spiel, dass du bei den Spawns echt permanent denkst, es ist einer hinter dir.
12 Kills, wo hat er die denn her?
Fake News.
Fake Nervous.
Ey, ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft?
Also, was ist mit dir verkehrt?
Erstens, was ist das für ein scheiß Waffensetup?
Und zweitens, was machst du da?
Och Gott.
Meine Güte.
Okay, Flankerino, Flankerino.
Warum prenamen die mich da schon?
Kann man hier außen rumflanken oder so?
Jaja.
Ja, das war kein Headshot.
Natürlich nicht.
Hehe, null.
Achtung, Heartbeat.
Okay, der hat volle Ghost Layout, Leute.
Der hat volle Ghost.
Volle Ghost-Taktik hat der.
Der hat die Cold-Blade-Ghost-Taktik gehabt, der Typ.
Volle Pulle.
Irgendwie bringen die Flank-Routen auch gar nichts.
Und das nächste HQ ist da hinten.
Das heißt, das heißt, die Gegner kommen jetzt hier?
Nee.
Ach, was auch immer.
Ich muss aufhören, ich muss aufhören, das Game versuchen zu verstehen.
Okay.
Okay, ich gehe jetzt hier oben hin.
Die müssen jetzt hier gleich reinpushen.
Dann gehen wir ans Fenster und bashen sie.
Von die links?
Ah, genau.
Wo war der jetzt?
Ja, der piekt das richtige Fenster.
Was ein Glück.
Er piekt das richtige Fenster.
Ich kriege Anfälle.
Ach, Chat.
Hätte schon mal die Waffe freigeschaltet, schon alles.
Piss dich, Aldo.
Wisst ihr, was der Nachteil ist, wenn man so viel spielt in den letzten Tagen?
Ich bin das ja nicht mehr gewöhnt.
Mir tun meine Ellenbogen weh.
Weil die auf der Armauflage die ganze Zeit hin und her geschoben werden.
Ja.
Das ist da abgeaimt hier.
Bin ich überhaupt noch mal gewohnt?
Jetzt ist jeder zugespotten.
Aldo, Yolo.
C4.
Okay, ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung, wo die sind.
Ich habe echt keinen Plan.
Absolut keinen.
Kein Schimmer.
Okay, links sind sie anscheinend.
Gucken wir mal.
Okay, Yolo sprint.
Ja.
Oh ja, sieben.
Aber guckt euch mal an.
Ich bin die ganze Runde rumgelaufen.
Nur rumgelaufen, habe keine Gegner gefunden.
Und der höchste hat 15.
Das heißt im Endeffekt, es ist die ganze Runde über wieder nichts passiert.
Gar nichts.
Du hast dir für dein Ellenbogen extra Polster geholt.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Was ist eigentlich mit dem Typ hier los gerade?
Willst du dich nicht vorwärts bewegen?
Reverse boostet er vielleicht.
Bei der Map immer quitten, ja.
Ja, da käme ich hier recht.
Jail Fever das Problem ist, was ich bei dem Spiel im normalen Multiplayer habe,
dass nur 80% der Maps einfach schlecht sind.
Und man kann auch nicht mal Maps voten.
Wenn man wenigstens Maps voten könnte.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich jetzt von der Seite gestellt oder so,
weil ich keine Ahnung habe, wo sie herkommen.
Komm, wir gehen erst mal hier gucken.
Am Mitte ist immer schwierig.
Mitte, Mitte, es sackt immer.
Es war schon immer so.
Nee.
Das war ein Gegner.
Shit.
Ich habe es nicht gesehen.
Keg W.
Hat er mich hier mehlt, gemehlt hat er mich.
Achtung hier.
Die Map macht mich echt fertig.
Ich gehe jetzt in unser Camperhaus.
Ich gehe jetzt ins Camperhaus.
Ja, oder so.
Oh nee.
Moment, Moment, Reck.
Ha, Turn on.
In your face.
Jetzt spielen wir mal richtig eklig.
Fuck, der hat es gecheckt.
Du bist die erste Person,
die dich im Multiplayer mit Herzschlag sensoriert.
Das liegt daran, weil das mein Warsorn Loadout ist,
was ich gerade drin habe.
Normalerweise ist der Herzschlag Sensor
im Multiplayer ziemlich errost.
Oh ja.
Achtung.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo ich aimen soll ehrlich gesagt hier.
Hier neben, wo ich geschimmelt habe gerade,
soll ich da wieder hin?
Okay.
Okay, jetzt sterben wir gleich,
wenn wir hier durchflanken.
Okay, okay, okay.
Gehen wir mal.
Achtung, Achtung.
Wie kommt man hier?
Haha, der Typ.
What?
Der ist hier aber gut ausgerüstet, ey.
Ah, der ist tot.
Okay Leute, easy, easy mode.
Achtung, ich zeige euch easy mode auf der Map.
Easy, easy mode.
Ach Moment, das ist Headquarters,
da bringt das ja gar nichts.
Das ist die Headquarters.
Okay, wir aimen jetzt jetzt einfach
3 Stunden ab, bis da irgendwas kommt.
3 Stunden ab aimen, bis irgendwas kommt.
Und wenn ich keinen Bock mehr habe.
Oh, da unten war noch einer.
Habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Ich darf den nicht repeaken, wenn ich den repeake, ist RIP.
Durch die Wand, Gewaltbangsort.
Jaja, regt dich ab.
Die Zeit ist fast fertig, guckt euch mal an.
Die Zeit ist fast fertig.
Mein Gott, ist das fail.
Wow, wow, wow, was zum?
Wer hat den gekillt?
Äh, okay.
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Die Zeit ist abgelaufen.
Was ist das wieder für ein Web, Alter?
So was hätte es früher nicht gegeben.
Nein, hätte es auch nicht.
Oh, wow.
Poggers, Alter.
Pog.
Huge.
Das war neu, das war nice.
Das war cool.
Okay, schauen wir mal, was die nächste Map ist.
Ah, Leute, Leute, dafür Mist.
Jetzt habe ich es verkackt.
Wisst ihr, was ich eben hätte einspielen können?
Den hier.
Der hätte gut gepasst, der hätte gut gepasst.
Get the camera.
Sollen wir mal schauen, ob wir Rage quitten müssen, je nach Map.
Somel, Somel, was zum Teufel?
Was war nochmal Somel?
Ach, die.
Ja, die Map sieht fast genauso aus wie die hier.
Nur, dass Windmühle in der Mitte ist.
Die Maps wirken eh alle ziemlich copy-pasted.
Mit der Krönung, die Krönung mit der Warzone-Map.
Die ist ja komplett copy-pasted.
Dafür ist Warzone der beste Spielmodus.
Alles andere hältst du da auf Dauer nicht aus.
Oh, guck mal, Sabrina ist am Start.
Bestimmt ein Hottes Gamer Grill.
Ja, genau, die ist das.
Guck, die sieht genau aus wie die andere Map,
bloß mit einer komischen Windmühle.
So, was spiele man da jetzt?
Eigentlich müsste ich ja Waffen anlocken.
Aber irgendwie, weiß nicht, irgendwie hätte ich dann doch
mal ganz gerne halbwegs gute Gameplay.
Das ist schwierig, schwierig, ja.
No Joke, das für Siegrill hieß Sabrina.
Sebaro, vielleicht habt ihr ja Gesprächsstoff.
Okay, wir campen jetzt hier ab.
Wir campen jetzt die Ecke ab hier.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die von hier kommen, aber...
Wie, das war kein Kill für mich?
Okay, moin, moin, moin.
Nicht so offensiv, dass es sinnlos ist.
Wir sitzen rum, Camp, hallo?
Camp Game?
Dementsprechend müssen wir der Sache auch Rechnung tragen
und schön sitzen, schön schimmeln, schön schimmeln.
So muss das sein, ja.
Genau, schöne Schimmel-Action.
Hoggers.
Ah, shit.
Vereimt, voll verkackt.
Ich war gerade dabei, die Maus zu resetten,
damit er kommt auf die Ecke.
Schön sitzen.
Erstmal hier, Renetti ist raus.
Ah, da warst du nix, Alter, da warst du nix.
Wow, Achtung, C4-Action.
Okay.
Oh, ist das ein Shotgun, Mensch?
Kriege ich heute noch mal Kills oder kriege ich nur Assists?
Okay, das war scheiße gamed.
Ja, ist gut, gebe ich zu.
So, der denkt jetzt, ich pieke links, der denkt, ich pieke links,
aber ich pieke rechts.
Und der denkt auch, ich pieke links, aber jetzt pieke ich links.
Big brain outplayed.
Wer ist der, Leute?
Alter, was ist das für ein Flitzer?
Ich komme mir vor wie so ein nackischer Typ auf dem Fußballfeld.
Was ist mit dem los gewesen?
Kann man eigentlich?
Ah, excellent.
Okay, wir haben uns viel zu viel bewegt,
wir müssen in unsere Schimmelposition übergehen.
Das geht aber gerade nicht.
Okay, hier ist auch gut, auch excellent Schimmelposition.
Excellent Schimmelposition, oder auch nicht.
Ah, nicht geguckt.
Tazer, du hast echt zu viel Geld für die 100 Cent, für den Euro quasi.
Das sind ja eine Million nordkoreanische Wonne,
haben wir letztens gelernt.
Boah, was ein Timing.
Und wie hat der erste schon wieder 30 Kills?
Es sind 100 Cent ungefähr, das kommt ziemlich genau hin.
Okay, Schimmelposition eingenommen.
Nein, das bin ich.
Ey, ich habe meine gute Position doch jetzt hier.
Meine Güte.
Wir können mp7 hier freispielen, oder?
Wenn wir da close reinkommen.
Aber da kommen wir nicht close rein.
Schreck mich nicht, dude.
Ernsthaft?
Ernsthaft hinter mir?
Ich gucke jetzt mal, was Sabrina macht.
What the hell?
Da stirbt keiner, oder?
An der Ecke.
Ja, jetzt stehen sie alle da.
Ich hätte gerne Kills, please.
Ich nehme mal ein paar Kills.
Wie toll am Start.
Bei der Waver kommt man an eine gute Map.
Oh, nee.
Voll verschissen.
Hier kommt bestimmt einer.
Hier kommt garantiert einer.
Wir legen uns mal auf.
Wir machen den richtigen Schimmelmodus jetzt.
Genau die Ecke.
Okay, der war glücklich, dass er so nah dran war.
Okay, Moment.
Nein, nein.
Jetzt können wir Waffen anlocken.
Wir kriegen gerade Edo auf den Sack.
Dann können wir Waffen anlocken.
Warum ist ein Gegner hinter mir?
Okay, wenigstens geht der erste Typ ab.
Hier geht es nicht weiter.
Okay, kann man hier lang pushen?
Wie riesig ist die Map?
Fuck, Alter.
Wie riesig die Map ist.
Hätte schon mal besser getroffen.
Okay, was machen wir jetzt?
Die andere anlocken?
Irgendwie geht da gerade nichts.
Aber das Coole ist, mich nervt das gar nicht mehr so.
Weil ich kann Waffen anlocken.
So blöds klingt.
Schön schimmeln an der Ecke.
So geht das.
Excellent.
So, und jetzt können wir da nicht lang gehen.
Weil dann raufen wir voll in das Elm von den Gegnern rein.
Okay, der flenkt.
Oder auch nicht.
Wow, doch.
Ja, von beiden Seiten.
Man sieht, wer sich bewegt, verliert.
Und die kriegen richtig auf den Sack die Runde gerade.
Obwohl ich ehrlich bin, ich weiß nicht, wie ich das großartig anders spielen soll.
Außer vielleicht die ein oder anderen Sachen mehr treffen.
Na, na, na.
Alter, wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Ich bin mit meiner Maus gerade nicht hinterher gekommen.
Wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Beweger, ey.
Das war richtiges Controller-Aim, ja.
Aber krass, wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Wie ist der denn geflitzt?
Ey.
Sag mal, leckt's?
Kann das sein, dass der gerade nicht geflitzt ist?
Ey, das ist schon wieder, seht ihr das?
Es ist schon wieder Time-Limit.
Der Modus sackt.
Müssen wir was anderes spielen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Hm.
Was geben wir uns denn mal?
Oh Mann, Gun-Game-Spielen habe ich noch nie gespielt.
Aber Knee-Kill-Confirmed ist zum größten Teil hier auch ziemlich blöd.
Ich hätte gerne Playlist, wo ich die Maps auswählen kann.
Ähm.
Das habe ich am Anfang gespielt, da bin ich aber durchgedreht bei.
Also ich habe ja schon die M4, die Renettis und zur Hälfte die MP7.
Gelevelt auf Dirty Old Boat mit Hardcore.
In Hardcore.
Dann wirst du blöd im Kopf mit der Zeit.
Ich wollte jetzt mal was anderes spielen zwischendurch.
Was habe ich denn, ich muss mal gucken.
Was habe ich denn eigentlich für eine K.D.?
Wo sieht man das denn?
Records, Multiplayer, Wins, nee.
Kills.
Oh.
Aber das ist normal in dem Game.
Ohne Scheiß, über 1,5 geht nicht.
Und ich spiele ja auch gar nicht drauf.
Aber trotzdem, man könnte, man könnte glaube ich eine Zweier vielleicht hinkriegen.
Aber, aber nur wenn man wirklich Hardcore tryhardert.
Oh nee.
Nee, nee.
Jetzt, jetzt nicht Leute, nee.
Das ist die schlimmste Map.
Das ist wirklich die schlimmste Map.
So, mal gucken wie Gun Game ist.
Ich muss gleich mal aufs Klo.
Ähm, by the way, wie wäre es eigentlich mal mit...
Gun Game ist richtig dumm.
Warum spiele ich Gun Game?
Ich will Waffen freischalten.
Eigentlich Massive, Massive, Pepega.
Der go live, drei Monate, Dankeschön.
Gibt es noch Free for All?
Ja.
Free for All, das ist auch Kacke in dem Spiel.
Es gibt nur so ein paar Modi, die weniger schlimm sind.
Ok, mal gucken wie Gun Game ist.
Ich habe noch kein einziges Gun Game gespielt.
Ähm, aber es stimmt nicht.
Chat, ich habe Mist erzählt.
Ich habe schon mal Gun Game gespielt.
Ok, mit was für einer Waffe fängt man an?
Ist das Burst?
Nee, das ist Single Schuss.
Wow, ich dachte da ist ein Gegner.
Was ist das?
Shotgun!
Das ist eine Shotgun!
A fucking Shotgun!
Ich habe eine Shotgun!
Wie soll das damit jetzt funktionieren?
Den Shotgun, ja?
Na klar, wir schießen beide mit der kleinen Shotgun auf Landerwärme.
Ich sterbe natürlich.
What the fuck?
Ok, was haben wir denn jetzt?
Was ist das?
Und das ist... ist das eine Burstwaffe?
Ich blick es nicht.
What the fuck ist das für eine Waffe?
Ok, da kommt jetzt von hinten gleich.
Oder auch nicht.
Was ist das?
Irgendwas mit Thermal?
Thermal Poggers?
Was?
Das war nicht drauf gerade?
Ach, das ist eine Shotgun!
Oder?
Was ist das für eine Waffe gewesen?
Das ist ein Granatwerf, oder?
Ich kenne die Waffen nicht.
Ey, was für ein Ding?
Ich blick null durch.
Übels lost, Alter, übels lost.
Aber das jetzt, das ist jetzt ein Raketenwerfer.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ich habe geschossen, losgelassen oder gegen die Wand geknallt.
Was für ein Modus.
Guck mal, wir sind gar nicht so schlecht.
Seht ihr das?
Und warum hat er Feuer an seiner Shotgun?
Hä?
Ok.
Und das ist, das ist, es hat Maschinen?
Ja, kein Headshot.
Aber das ist das, das hat Maschinen.
Ok, das schaut mal gut.
Und das, was ist das?
Ist das ein Looptube?
Unten rechts.
Ah, das ist ein Assault Rifle.
Ok, ich muss sagen, aus irgendwelchen Gründen macht das sogar halbwegs Spaß.
Wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat an die Waffenrotation, ist das glaube ich ganz nice.
Aber das können wir nicht spielen, weil, das müssen wir uns, man muss sich das angucken,
oder wie?
Weil ich will Waffen anlocken.
Leute wollen wir noch ein Gun Game spielen und dann Waffen anlocken?
Irgendwie macht das Bock.
Zumal ich, ich kenne ja 90% der Waffen in dem Spiel gar nicht.
Komm, eins, eins, ein Gun Game spielen wir noch.
Mal schauen, wie die Map, welche Map kommt.
So und danach machen wir Weapon XP rein und dann müssen wir leider, leider wieder in die,
in die schlimme Playlist.
Hast du schon eine GPU mit N4Eng?
Was der Stream verpixelt bei schnellen Bewegungen?
Was?
Ernsthaft?
Das Ding hat 8,9 MBit oder so, da sollte eigentlich nichts passieren.
Ja, ich habe eine mit N4Eng, ja ich mache aber CPU-Encoding, aber das sollte, das sollte
doch nichts verpissen.
Oh.
Was ist denn das für eine Dreckswaffe?
What the fuck, was ist das?
Warum schießt die nicht, wenn man triggert?
Was ist das?
Verpixels, chat, verpixels wirklich hart?
Ich muss mir das gleich mal selbst angucken.
Oh, in den Bauch geschossen reicht nicht.
Ach, das ist ein Autosniper.
Ok, was auch immer.
Was auch immer ey, warum leuchte ich jetzt grün?
Das ist, ist das ein Sniper?
Alter, was für ein Sniper, what the fuck?
Ok, ich kenne die Waffen nicht, das ist scheiße.
Oh.
What?
Das ist aber fail, dass es kein Kill war.
Wow, wow, wow, fuck, ich habe mich ein wenig gedrückt,
haha.
Oh, Launcher.
Leute, es wird gelauncht.
Ah, shit.
Oh, wir sind dritter, poggers.
Poggers.
Die Schritte kamen doch eindeutig von hinten.
WTF?
Hallo?
Ich habe links geklickt, er hat nicht geschossen.
Oh, der wollte mich messern, habt ihr das gesehen?
Der Messer Dude.
Oh, nee, was?
Victory?
Ah, nee, ich bin dritter geworden, ok.
Ah, man kann nicht leaven, ich will raus.
Komms da, ja, die Maps sind echt nicht nice.
Ok, wir müssen wieder in die schlimme Playlist rein.
Presque, jetzt sieht es crisp aus, ja, muss so sein.
Was heißt Ragequitter?
Ich will mir nicht den Kram angucken, warum soll ich jetzt 30 Sekunden rumsitzen und nichts machen?
Wozu?
So Leute, wir müssen leider, leider müssen wir wieder.
Komm, wir können auch mal die normale spielen, aber ich sage euch, die sind nicht besser.
Die sind nicht besser.
Ok, Weapon Talks, zack.
Jetzt gehts ab.
Jetzt gibt es wenigstens XP für die Waffen.
Und danach spielen wir noch eine Runde Solo Warthorn.
Obwohl ich sage, wie gesagt, da kriege ich Anfälle, da muss man so krass stelzen.
Ach, kommt mal ein Playstation-Spieler mit Maus und Tastatur.
Vielleicht weiß das einer von euch.
Man kann ja auf der Playstation 4 Crossplay ausschalten.
Wie sieht es denn aus, wenn man auf der Playstation mit Maus und Tastatur spielt?
Wenn man auf der Playstation mit Maus und Tastatur spielt, kann man dann Crossplay ausschalten oder ist immer automatisch Crossplay?
Dann kommst du im PC sicher, ja.
Und wenn ich mit Leuten groope, wenn ich mit Leuten groope, ist dann automatisch Crossplay an.
Oh, Shipment, da habe ich ja drauf gewartet.
Wird ja Zeit, dass wir mal wieder Shipment spielen.
So, wir probieren jetzt mal was, ob wir oben drauf kommen.
Aber wahrscheinlich sind wir schon down, bevor wir auch nur ansatzgeweise oben drauf sind.
Ich weiß gar nicht mal, von wo.
Ey, Shipment, Alter.
Shipment macht mich fertig.
Shipment, hinter mich spawnen.
Viel Shipment, please.
Scheiße, mein MP7 ist leer.
Was bist du, Schaunt?
Shipment. 10 gegen 10, glaube ich, oder so.
Voll für den Arsch, aber Waffen liefern sich gut.
Das ist normal, das ist normal auf Shipment, aber da kann ich den Kram auch Hardcore spielen.
Deswegen, Leute, ihr seht, es ist kein Unterschied.
Das einzige Unterschied ist, dass du mehr stirbst in Softcore,
weil du nicht so viele Leute wegrotzen kannst aus der Hüfte.
Oh, es geht weiter, Hardcore-Shipment.
Exzellent.
Als hätte man drauf gewartet.
Als hätte man drauf gewartet, nur.
Einmal Shipment, immer Shipment.
The enemy.
The enemy took the hardpoint.
What the hell, Alter?
Chopper Gunner?
A fucking Chopper Gunner am Start.
Shipment, please.
Warum habe ich diese Dreckswaffe jetzt aufgehoben? Die wollte es schon gar nicht.
Shipment, Alter, Shipment.
What the hell?
Das ist so kaputt.
Zeit zum Nachladen hat man natürlich nicht.
Ich aim die jetzt hier ab.
Oh fuck, Teammate.
Fragt mich nicht, was ihr hier gerade seht.
Ihr seht, sinnloses Spielmodus auf der sinnlosen...
Nee, der Spielmodus ist ganz gut.
Ihr seht, Infinity War's Inkompetenz irgendwie versinnvoll ist zu remaken.
Warum gibt es keine Playlist?
Oldschool Maps?
Oldschool Maps Playlist?
What the hell?
Ey, ist der Wahnsinn.
Jetzt wisst ihr übrigens auch, warum ich so eine Scheiß-K.D. habe.
Weil ich den ganzen Kram gespielt habe zu 90%.
Ist der gerade hinter uns gespawnt?
Der ist hinter uns gespawnt.
What?
Von wo?
Also 3 versus 3 würde ich sagen, okay, das mag noch gehen oder so.
Aber alles andere...
Meine Fresse.
Hör auf, ich muss noch kurz aufs Klo.
Wir klagen wieder da.
Ich mach nicht mehr weiter.
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir haben eine gescheite Map.
Kek.
Double U.
Cranked. Oh, das wird wieder was.
Hält hier irgendeiner die Ecke?
Das ist wieder instant gefickt.
Also Run, Gun ist hier echt nicht ohne.
What?
Äußerst fair.
Ey, sag mal, darf ich mal was töten wenn ich treffe?
Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Alter, schieß nicht auf mich.
What?
Kann mir irgendeiner erklären von was ich gerade einen Punkt gekriegt habe?
Ver-aimed, mega ver-aimed.
Ha.
Wow.
Ich dachte, den kann ich aus der Hüfte spreien.
Konnte ich nicht.
Aber kannste mal probieren.
Oh, ich bin Cranked.
Meine Güte, warum treffe ich aus der Hüfte mit der Kackwaffe nicht?
Die ist extra gemacht, um aus der Hüfte zu spreien.
Kekona-aim, ja.
Hardcore Kekona-aim.
Aber man muss aus der Hüfte spreien, das ist der einzige Vorteil, den man damit hat.
Auf Range.
Das ist echt hardcore.
Guck hier, so muss man aus der Hüfte schießen.
Dann taugt es aber was.
Wow.
4Crip, bringt der was für Hit Accuracy?
Oh Gott, wie der eng steht.
Nee, da gehe ich nicht ab.
Anstrengend, anstrengende Sache.
Was?
Wie krass, wie krass hat er das, wenn er das gemacht hat.
Wo die eckige Jump-Bam tut.
Doch, es ist heftig.
Einmal so verrexte ich 5x in Folge, weil du instant geowned wirst.
Oh, der kommt von hinten.
Vorne auch nicht.
Easy.
Das juckt, aber Auge.
Was?
Wir haben schon verloren?
Ja, die Crank-Sachen zählen doppelt.
Du musst mehr in der Ecke schwitzen für mehr Kills.
Das ist korrekt, aber da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Für aus der Hüfte den Merk-Crip drauf, echt?
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
Ah, ich darf hier nichts einstellen.
Übrigens Leute, ich bin fast schon Level 100, ich spiele seit 5 Tagen wieder.
Was haben wir da?
Nein, das ertrage ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Okay, zeig mal.
Was für ein Crip?
Meinst du hier?
Den da?
Aim Down Sidespeed.
Du meinst, der ist verbugged und Aim Down Sidespeed wird nicht affected?
Exzellent.
Genauso mag ich das.
Bug-Using.
Who cares?
Aber 60-Round-Mac muss sein.
Man hat eh schon...
Ah, Aim Down Speed.
Ne, vielleicht auch nicht.
Perks machen wir mal raus.
Bald haben wir das letzte.
Damage Range, das machen wir mal weg.
Aim Down Sidespeed immer exzellent.
Wobei Bullet-Velocity sollte man nicht machen.
Da brauchen wir 50.
Ah, die machen wir noch.
Die 4 Level machen wir noch.
Laser.
Sprint.
Rear-Crip.
Sprint to...
Sprint to Fire.
Sehr gut.
No Stock.
Stock ist hier...
Ne, das ist Barrel.
Ach hier, Stock.
Ah.
Hast du doch nicht?
Ne, ich hab auch nicht.
Ähm, vielleicht lohnt sich doch, dass ich die...
Aber Movement Speed, Movement Speed will ich eigentlich nicht weniger haben.
Slide of Hand ist gut, Slide of Hand ist gut.
Ja, Slide of Hand geht aber nur nachdem man was gekillt hat.
Also ich mach dann später den Suppressor drauf.
Macht das überhaupt viel aus, hier?
Der Unterschied?
Zwischen nichts, 50 und 60?
Ich mein, die Anzeigen kann man ja eh nicht glauben, was da drin steht.
Wahrscheinlich ist es vollkommen egal.
Spielen wir mal ne Runde.
Combination.
Und dann hoffentlich auf ne guten Map.
Die größeren Max merkst du wirklich, okay?
Dann geh ich vielleicht mal raus.
Ah gut.
Ich mein, es reicht ja um einzukillen.
Was machen wir da jetzt noch drauf?
Ich mein, das Ding ist halt...
Bullet Velocity ist schon nicht schlecht.
Komm, wir machen das nochmal drauf.
Slide of Hand haben wir doch drinnen, oder?
Ich glaub, Slide of Hand hab ich reingemacht.
Ich glaub, das ist ne Kackmap.
Kappa, wer hätte das gedacht?
Guck mal, Ghost Fanboy.
Welche Map ist denn das nochmal gewesen?
Denk, denk, denk.
Ach, die.
Die geht.
Da muss man sich in das...
Man muss nur durchkommen.
Man muss sich in das Haus campen.
Man muss sich...
Moment, haben wir eigentlich Hardcore?
Man muss sich in das Haus campen, das ist wichtig.
Hier, in dem Haus muss man campen.
Das beste Spot im ganzen Gamer, Haus campen.
Ein nicer Haus Camper.
Ich hab zu wenig Schuss.
Juff.
Jutsch, Haus Camping, Vollgas.
Das Game ist so ein Drecks-Camp-Spiel.
Unglaublich, unglaublich.
Ist gut, Tür zu.
Und Schuss.
Tür auf.
Okay, Trick 17.
Nice, weggesprayt.
Hier camp ich immer an der Ecke.
Ich hab gedacht, das macht jetzt vielleicht auch einer.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Mehr als hitten kann man nicht, ne?
Okay, wir müssen mal B wiederholen.
Der campt hier drin, der macht das so wie ich.
Ah, Flagge, Flagge.
Come on, brah.
Hier movet sich einmal wieder gar keiner.
Niemand bewegt sich.
Mertur Dom.
Ich fass es nicht.
Hat er wirklich Mertur Dom gespielt gerade?
Hab ich das richtig gesehen, ja?
Was für ein Camp, ey.
Achtung, jetzt machen wir noch mehr excellent Camping.
Okay.
Was ein sinnloses Romrecamper.
Egal, weil das Game Will ist von mir.
Oh, zwei Stück.
Das Game Will ist halt von mir, was willst du machen, ja?
Man kriegt ja auch fürs Capture nichts mehr.
WTF, ich muss das drücken, nicht werfen.
Ich zeige euch mal beste Camp-Pose.
Ja.
Ah, der ist doch wirklich neben mir vorbeigelaufen jetzt.
By the way, ich glaube, ich mach mir noch eine Hardline-Klasse, dann erreiche ich auch...
Fuck, mehr Killstreak.
Man muss es hier nur ins Warehouse schaffen, dann ist Easy Mode.
Alter, überall sitzt einer.
Ghost ist viel zu gut, ja, da hast du recht.
Ghost ist das Wichtigste.
Du kannst ja auch normales Warzone nicht richtig spielen ohne Ghost.
Also ich meine, doch kannst du, das stimmt nicht.
Es gibt genug, die spielen auf Akill oder sowas.
Aber es ist schon deutlich angenehmer mit Ghost.
Das Gespray über die halbe Map.
Kann man nicht rüber springen.
WTF, what?
Wo kam der Dude denn her jetzt?
Und was trifft mich hier gerade?
Und warum haben wir das nicht eingenommen?
Und warum kommen da jetzt 30 Millionen Gegner?
Ja, deswegen will ich mir auch zwei Klassen machen.
Deswegen will ich mir auch zwei Klassen machen.
Die Map ist übrigens ganz gut.
Da kann man nämlich die Laufwege der Gegner erahnen.
Ich finde das gut, wenn die Maps nicht zu chaotisch sind.
Die kommen jetzt von unten hier.
WTF, was ist das da oben?
Kann man da hoch?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Erinnere mich mal please nach der Runde, dass ich die Killstreaks ein bisschen lauer mache.
Das Problem ist, es gibt eigentlich gar keine richtig guten Killstreaks, die ich haben will.
Wie toll ist der einzige gute Killstreak, der sinnvoll platziert ist?
Der Rest ist irgendwie zu hoch, wenn man run und gunnt.
Und die Predator ist halt in dem Spiel richtig schlecht.
Ich wusste, in irgendeiner Ecke kämpfst du.
Ich wusste, dass du in irgendeiner Ecke sitzt.
Ich wusste nicht in welcher und man sieht den ja auch so schlecht.
Man hätte aimen können, aber ich habe gedacht, das ist nicht notwendig.
Aber trotzdem.
Ich war eins mit februär gesessen.
Warum soll ich mich bewegen?
Oh wir haben Tripple, Tripple, Tripple Cap.
Gegner.
Oh Shit.
Ach man, der Typ.
Der spezialisiert auf das Gebäude.
Ich sehe da schon.
Warum sterben die denn nicht?
Ja ich treffe nicht alles, aber umkippen dürfen sie trotzdem.
Mein Ellenbogen tut weh.
Alter Scheibenwischer.
Das tut echt mein Ellenbogen weh.
Oh da ist aber einer scharf auf mich.
E-Sport ist kein Sport, Max holt sich sogar eine Ellenbogenverletzung.
Mir tut richtig der Ellenbogen weh.
Ich glaube, ich muss da mal Kisten drunter legen.
Ich habe ja den, den kennt ihr ja, den habe ich euch ja schon mal gezeigt.
Den Stuhl.
Und der hat ansonsten eigentlich recht angenehme Läden.
Aber für 8 Stunden ärmelloses Hemd ist das zu hart.
Richtig, es ist kein Gaming Stuhl.
Aber Gaming Stühle sind eroverrated.
Ich muss übrigens mal gucken, dass ich keine Subs übersehen habe.
Dergolife hat Resub, 3 Monate, Dankeschön.
Ich glaube, habe ich schon vorher gelesen, aber trotzdem, huge.
Er ist kein Hemd, T-Shirt halt, kurzärmlich.
Au, au, die Killstreaks runterstellen, ja.
Oh nee, es kommt auch Asiakalf, geh fort.
Was für sinnvolle Killstreaks gibt es da eigentlich?
Die Predator ist halt rotz.
Die braucht viel zu lang.
Der Cluster Strike macht keine Kills.
Der Precision Air Strike, der geht sogar noch halbwegs.
Der muss man aber gut setzen und außerdem rennen alle weg.
Mit dem killst du eigentlich auch sehr wenig.
Ich glaube, ich mache wieder das da.
Das hatte ich nämlich auch die ganze Zeit vorher,
heute habe ich umgestellt hier auf Chopper Gunner
und mal White Phosphorus ausprobiert.
Das ist übrigens richtig gut.
Das ist richtig nice, da gewinnt man die Runde fast sicher
und macht auch ganz gut Kills zwischendurch,
weil die Gegner so blöd sind und ins Feuer rennen.
Bisher hatte ich immer das hier als Loadout.
Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was man nehmen kann, glaube ich.
Tja.
Was?
Installing Shader?
Warum installierst du hier irgendwelche Shader?
Modern Warfare muss man nicht nachvollziehen.
Okay, wir machen jetzt mal wirklich komplett den YOLO-Modus.
Alles, wir haben jetzt alles drin.
Mal gucken, was da jetzt kommt.
Wahrscheinlich ist gleich Rage Quit-Time angesagt.
So, und wenn ich die MP7 auf Level 50 habe,
habe ich die vielleicht sogar schon auf Level 50.
Ha!
Dann spielen wir eine Runde Warzone.
Nee, spielen wir nicht, weil ich noch XP Boost habe.
14 Minuten, 14 Minuten.
14 Minuten haben wir schon Weapon Boost.
Die nutzen wir noch aus.
Jetzt können wir auch den Suppressor dran machen.
Wahrscheinlich ist das Setup jetzt übelst kacke mit dem Lauf.
Oh, ich habe den Suppressor an der Fatsch.
Keine Ahnung.
Probieren wir mal.
TDM.
Ohje, Leute.
TDM Warehouse.
Probieren wir mal No Stock.
Mach ich, mach ich.
Okay, hier hat keiner Bock.
Hier hat wirklich keiner Bock.
Hier hat absolut gar keiner Bock.
Was?
Oh, der Cleverino.
Huge IQ Play.
Die Perk, dass man im Rennen schießen kann,
ist ganz übelst geil in Black Ops 2, war das glaube ich.
What the fuck?
Okay, ich blicke nicht durch, wo da was herkommt.
Okay, der hat sieben Kills.
What the fuck, wie hat er das denn gemacht?
Ich weiß ja nicht, wie man hier laufen muss auf der Map.
Der sitzt wahrscheinlich irgendwo.
Links hat Run und Gun, kannst du voll knicken.
Ah, ich habe eine Idee.
Wisst ihr, was wir jetzt mal machen?
Edit.
Quick Fix.
Wir probieren es mal aus.
Habe ich die falsche, habe ich die falsche Klasse ausgewählt?
Habe ich die falsche Klasse ausgewählt?
Ach, M4 habe ich.
Okay Leute, wir sind zu mobil, das funktioniert in dem Spiel nicht.
Ich muss jetzt wieder chillen, sonst wird das nichts.
Sonst wird das nichts.
Guckt es euch an?
What the fuck?
Von wo?
Meine Güte.
Okay, mehr sitzen Max, mehr sitzen, nicht zu viel bewegen.
Ich spiele das ja wie jedes andere Call of Duty, das geht ja.
Every empty Ecke.
Das sah bei mir nicht so aus.
What the fuck?
Was war denn das wieder?
Haben die ersten Hits nicht gezählt oder?
Was war das wieder?
Mal gucken vor, wo da was ist.
Stim?
Nee, der hat geleckt.
Sau.
Jetzt sind sie natürlich auf der komplett anderen Seite.
Ich muss den Stim benutzen, Alter, warum benutze ich den Stim nicht?
Crossfire, sehr schön.
Guckt euch mal, ich bin Zweiter, warum das da?
Kann man hier hoch?
Von allen Seiten her.
Übrigens, das ist hier das Pro-Movement, das habe ich mir schon abgeguckt für Warzone.
Du musst sprinten, hinspeisen, sprinten, hinspeisen, sprinten, hinspeisen, sprinten, hinspeisen, sprinten, hinspeisen.
Und dann sterben.
Da gehen sie, oh fuck.
Oh, last kill, komm, killcam, gib mir mal eine killcam, gib mir mal eine killcam, please.
Das muss doch die killcam gewesen sein.
Leute, ich habe Hunger, ich muss mal kurz Brötchen reinbeißen.
Jetzt, hier, Poggers.
Endlich mal eine killcam.
Nee, du musst den Slide glaube ich nicht cancelen.
Du kannst tactical sprint, slide und dann gleich wieder tactical sprint machen.
Das habe ich ganz gecheckt.
Und das Schlimme ist, 14.9 ist ein guter Score in dem Spiel.
Oh, Level 100.
Gibt 155. Stimmt, was gibt es hier eigentlich kostenlos?
Ohje, die Map, die geht, die geht.
Ganz ehrlich, die hätten sich sparen können, dieses ganze Killcam, Scoreboardgezeige und die Introflüge.
Einfach, joinen, los.
Hier kommt jetzt einer rein.
Schimmeln haben wir gesagt.
Easy shim laws.
Hallo Gegner, wie ist es?
Ein Gegner, Hallo.
Gegner.
Findest einen Gegner und zack, natürlich schon gleich.
Ich weiß nicht, run and gun ist irgendwie so eine Sache.
Ok Leute, es bleibt uns leider nichts.
Achso Moment, ich habe mich verguckt, wir haben ja Ghosts noch.
Bis denn Janik.
Danach spielen wir eine Runde solo Warzone, wenn es vorbei ist.
Es geht immer ganz entscheidend auf die Gegner an, ob man da reinlaufen kann oder nicht.
Aber die liegen so krass wieder.
Du kommst überhaupt nirgendwo hin.
Wo ist dieser Typ?
Das war das Claws.
Wie ging das?
Yo mother.
Ticken zu spät.
Ein Ticken zu spät, brauner Marok, danke für den Sub.
Hallo, Gegner, gib mir Gegner.
Ich gehe hier nicht aus dem Haus raus Leute, das könnt ihr vergessen.
Ich sag's euch, glaubt es mir, gehst aus dem Haus raus, bist tot.
Guck mal, das funktioniert.
Das ist so das Pro-Movement.
Ok Leute, der will es nicht anders.
Er will es nicht anders.
Moment, hier geht es rein.
Ok, wo sind sie denn?
Ich brauch Gegner.
Wenn er Renettis will, kann er die haben.
Aber jetzt seh ich nichts mehr.
Ok, der Renetti Dude ist weg.
Fuck.
Gegner, komm mal her.
Ok, dann müssen wir doch mit der M4 ran.
Erst mal schön die CSGO-Up-Aim-Taktik machen.
Nur, dass irgendwie nichts da ist.
Ich will einen um Renettin.
Und wenn es das Einzige ist, was ich die Runde mache.
Ich charge da jetzt durch.
Ja, ah fuck.
Der muss Renettin werden.
Jawoll, ok.
Wir können wieder eine ordentliche Waffe nehmen.
Es wäre richtig geil, wenn ich ein paar Gegner sehen würde.
Das wäre massiv Poggers.
Die haben mir einfach die Tür in die Fresse gehauen.
Fuck.
Das C4 war absolut big brain, next level.
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Ha, von drüben, von drüben wär ich gekillt.
Nee, es gibt den Aufsatz-Freischalter-Bug, gibt's nicht mehr.
Ok, wir spielen wieder was ordentliches.
Genug Cowboy-Pistols.
Ok, wir gucken jetzt mal, dass wir gewinnen.
Wir gucken mal, dass wir gewinnen jetzt.
Du bist über mich, oder?
Alter, wie du überall abgeaimt wirst.
Das ist Core.
Und übrigens, die sterben in Core tatsächlich so schnell mit der Waffe.
Also, die Dinger des Dinges, krass.
Ihr seht das richtig?
Die Runde.
Guckt euch mal, wie da geschimmelt wurde.
54 zu 56.
So, ich esse jetzt kurz mein Brötchen fertig und dann gammel ich mal wirklich eine Runde
von Warzone und Solo rum, aber sag euch, erwartet nix, ne?
Warzone will oder anzappen?
Ich glaub, man kann da nicht anzappen.
So, Max, hast du Bock?
Jo.
Stream so aber gerade.
Chat leak.
Kräfti, Twitch Prime.
Ah, man sieht nix.
Oh nee, oh nee.
Die Map.
Och, please.
Das ist die schlimmste.
Das ist wirklich das aller, aller Schlimmste in diesem Spiel.
Die Map, Alter.
Die Map.
Shitmaid.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Wir müssen hier weg.
Alter, die Ease-Map.
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Ja, klar.
Vereimt.
Aber die Map ist so schlimm.
Das ist echt ohne Scheiß, Leute, das ist die schlimmste.
What?
Alter.
Da ist oben Gesetze.
Ah, ich will wieder pushen.
Alter, ich würd gern laufen.
What the hell.
Die Map, die macht mich echt...
Die Map macht mich so fertig.
Die sieht ja optisch sogar ganz gut aus.
Aber die spielt sich einfach shit.
Wo ist denn hier überhaupt was?
Es ist hier komplett random, ob den Gegner forst, wie es hier läuft oder nicht.
Es ist einfach komplett...
Ich dachte, da steht einer.
Es ist komplett random.
Ja, klar.
So, machen wir das.
Perfekt.
Easy as fuck.
What?
Das macht mich fertig.
Die macht mich...
Die bringt mich an den Rand der Verzweiflung.
Das ist hart, Gus.
Das ist wirklich... da musst du Schmerzesgeld für bezahlen.
Da musst du echt Schmerzesgeld für bezahlen für die Map.
Streamsniper, ja, bestimmt.
Muss Streamsniper sein.
Da fuck, diese Map, ich fäll verrückt.
Okay, Leute, Moment.
Easy.
Jetzt, Snipe, xxHD.
xxHD.
xxHD, Snipes.
Ah, das ist ja wie toll.
Ja, warte mal, xxHD, Snipes.
Ice Snipes, x360.
Easy.
Next face member hier.
Next.
Ich sage, next.
Wer ist denn gerade angesagter Sniper?
You and Chris, baby.
Wer ist denn gerade Sniper?
Der Sniper, Gott.
Face Wobblers, ja.
Alter, die Map.
Okay, okay.
Ice Snipes, Ice Scopes Wobblers.
What, okay.
Hier ist nichts.
Ice Scopes.
Jetzt scope ich, sonst kommt nichts.
360.
Ich glaube, ich habe was zu essen hier bei mir stehen.
Ich habe nicht genug Platz, um Mousepad zu 60 zu machen.
Achtung, Leute.
Von hinten.
Alter, das ist...
Die Map macht mich so fertig.
Warum bin ich erster mit sieben Kills?
Das geht doch gar nicht.
Jetzt weiter, sorry.
Ice Snipes HD.
Die haben Bock.
Oh, jetzt wurde er gesnipet.
Max, nach der Runde lade ich dich ein.
Das wird dann, ja, da haben wir doppelt Max am Start.
Haben wir noch einen dritten?
Und ihr müsst Ansagen machen, ne?
Ich bin doch nicht so eine Warzone-Pro.
What the fuck?
Die Map ist wirklich legit Körperverletzung.
Legit Körperverletzung.
Was weiß?
Wie was weiß einfach?
Na und, stirbt nicht?
Die Max, das neue RTL-Serie.
Jetzt ist er da hinten.
Kann ich den Metro-Map machen?
Auch nicht ein Hit, krass.
Mega, ey.
Aber wenigstens haben wir den noch.
High IQ-Aim war das eben wieder.
Oh, wir haben gar keine Muni mehr.
Achtung, jetzt gehen wir da runter.
Wir haben uns gebasht.
Oh, jetzt haben wir einen.
Was ist das?
Fahr' ma' mal ne Runde.
What the hell?
Beste Pose für so Wilson gewesen.
Gib Gas!
Ich bin sicher, das ist ein Hardpoint.
Da können die nix gegen machen.
Drei Mal ein Max bei CSGO, stimmt wahr?
Als wir CSGO gespielt haben, haben wir triple Max da.
Okay Max, invites zu mich, soll ich dich invite?
Und ich muss mal in-game-Voice anmachen.
What? Was jetzt?
Hallo? Game?
Was?
Was macht das Spiel für Dinger wieder?
Max, ich starte mal kurz neu.
Du hast Push, du Torchern, ja will ich auch.
Sonst kann ich nicht mit dem Chat labern.
Was mache ich während der Runde wahrscheinlich eh nicht.
Jetzt alles, was ich sage, hören die.
Leaked, schon wieder.
Was ist jetzt schon wieder leaked?
Pack one.
Okay, was?
Okay, wir lassen das Game at Shader installieren.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist auf einmal für Schmerzen.
Nee, das macht das Game nur einmal, bei mir macht das nie sonst.
Ah, so Max, bin da.
Wie war das jetzt?
Haben wir jetzt noch einen dritten oder nicht?
Hallo, hallo?
Hallo?
Hörst du uns?
Ja, wir sind angeblich nur zwei, aber drei sind im Voice-Chat, perfekt.
Warum sind wir angeblich nur zwei?
Achso, hier.
Weil das Game der Meinung ist, wir sind nur zwei.
Das übliche.
Kann ich direkt suchen, oder?
Wir haben angeblich noch einen Flexi, 96 oder sowas.
Ah, du bist ultra leise, ich verstehe dich kaum.
Echt?
Aber Max, bei dir ist normal, oder?
Ja, bei mir alles gut.
Das kriegen wir hin.
Aber du kannst suchen.
Also ihr müsst mir sagen, wo es lang geht.
Ich bin da noch ein bisschen verplant.
Wie sieht es bei euch aus?
Seid ihr schon die Experten?
Ja, naja.
Ein paar Mal Win war schon drin, dementsprechend soll es schon gehen.
Kriegt man hin?
Nee.
Strange, weil ich habe jetzt gerade alles hochgestellt.
Ja, kann ich nachher auch eine Runde mitmachen.
Ich verstehe ihn ganz gut.
Also, ich wollte jetzt eigentlich eher solos spielen und eine Runde Trios.
Ich wollte keine Chat-Games machen.
Ja, du kannst suchen.
Ja, notfalls mache ich halt hier den Dolmetscher sozusagen.
Ja.
Also Chat, die Pros, die droppen immer Storage-Town.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir Pro genug sind, Storage-Town zu droppen.
Storage-Town und Warehouse droppen die immer.
Also die, die dann World-Record-Kills-Gameways erspielen und so.
Ja, aber ich glaube, wir sind nicht Pro genug.
Wo wollen wir droppen?
Oh, ich glaube, ich muss Voice-Chat unbedingt lauter machen.
Leute, Chat, versteht ihr die zwei überhaupt?
Klatsch.
So, sag mal bitte was.
Hallo.
Ja, ich habe dich ein bisschen lauter gemacht, aber trotzdem, man versteht es nicht wirklich.
Aber es passt schon.
Mich auch nicht oder?
Doch, doch, dich halbwegs.
Ich war mal ein bisschen lauter.
Halbwegs ist ja...
Moment bitte.
Aber es passt schon.
Mich auch nicht, oder?
Ja.
Doch, doch.
Dich, dich halbwegs.
Ich war mal ein bisschen lauter.
Halbwegs ist ja...
Ja, so ist gut.
So ist gut.
In-Game viel zu laut.
Ah.
Natürlich in-Game viel zu laut, weil das Game sich wieder umgestellt hat.
Max, öffnen Sie bitte die Map.
Ja, wo wollen wir hin?
Da, hier wo markiert ist.
Grün?
Yes.
Okay.
So, dann wollen wir gleich mal.
So, wollen wir mal, ha?
Oh, das ist ja fast Storagetown, wo wir droppen, ja.
Das ist richtig, aber dann können wir uns von außen ein bisschen vorarbeiten.
Ich bin ja mal gespannt, Chat, ob das was wird, ja.
Aber schon mal die Pro Fallschirmstrats am Start.
Money, Money, Money.
Das schafft gar nicht.
Das ging schnell.
Max, hörst du mich noch?
Ja.
Ja, wunderbar, weil ich hab kein hier Lautsprecher-Symbol mehr.
Ich schwöre dich aber.
Schlecht.
Nee, ich schwöre dich aber noch.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Lieber ne Schneiber, bevor ich die kack Shotgun mitnimm.
Storagetown ist schon was.
Kann man theoretisch rüber.
Wie schaut's denn bei dir mit dem Loot aus?
Geht halbwegs.
Dann brauchen wir auch noch einen.
Aber das klappt.
Gehen wir da mal noch zwei Tanker rüber und dann gehen wir.
Lass mal nicht auf der Straße stehen bleiben.
Da kommt noch, da kommt noch mehr.
Direkt.
Ich komm mal rüber.
Wow.
Nee, nee, nee, Kollege.
Übelsreudige Waffe, Alter.
Ich seh's wieder keinen mehr.
Links war einer noch, an der Richtung Tankstelle.
es war glaube ich anderes team das sind die kreu oder das sind die kreu
hier mitte am wagen am train bing
das war weg ja
wir müssen weg das wir haben kaum rüstung und nix oder wie viel sind da oben vielleicht
können die posten aber ich glaube nicht ja ja dann gehe ich brauche mal nicht eine gescheite
waffe ich habe kein geld
ich habe jetzt eingestellt dass wir dass ich nicht push to talk drücken muss
die westen garantiert hier ist ja nichts ist ja gar nichts ist absolut tote hose oder ghost
oder ghost am start jetzt noch nicht das ist zu früh okay also plan wo gehen wir hin
tankstelle da oben kommt einer der will da rein trocken wieder hinten egal lassen wir
immer habt ihr den huge snipe geschehen gesehen schatt money money gibt es mal gescheite waffe
aber wirklich viel ist ja nicht zu bieten ist ja nicht drin aber man rüber zu den zu den
häuser wenn wir hier fertig sind ja ich würde eher das auto nehmen und in sieben ok das
kann man so nicht leisten was gibt das hier
so spielen die pros in solos immer die fahren die ganze zeit rum steigen casual aus und
killen leute wir könnten mal ein paar auftreten der sound den haben sie auch in fünf minuten
die night so ich gucke mal ob ich sehe wo ihr ihr seid noch gar nicht drin
wir sind zusammen ja das auto
so easy will einfach flagge so jetzt ist die große preisfrage wo gehen wir hin zum loadout
können wir nicht dann ist ribb das ist am hochhaus
schauen wir mal
mit wahnsinnig viel schuss doppelt odi bis heraus die haben sich gekillt oder ich bin
jetzt bin ich allein perfekt ich hätte wollte mich so spielen sehen ich brauche mal irgendwas
hier ist ja auch nichts da ok zeig mal wie sie in die zone aus irgendwie bis sie
luft ich habe ihn gerade kritisiert sorry ich habe nichts verstanden team building maßnahmen
beste da spricht der personale ist ja gar nichts mehr also magst du darf beruhigt sagen
wo ich hin soll was ich machen soll
das ist vielleicht jetzt mal ein bisschen wo sieht man denn wo es aufträge gibt überhaupt
eigentlich auf dem map aber es sind wahrscheinlich was wo es nicht echt nicht gesehen auf dem
loch also platten habe ich jetzt genug markieren auch mal wo ich hin da hinten ist ja nix an
geld
aus hamann da
ist echt brutal wenig kohle hier
oder lohnt sich das hier oben wahrscheinlich kommt uns hier um nochmal durchzuluten da ist
aber die feuerwehr ok da ist aber auch bestimmt leer oder ist es überhaupt noch feuerwehr
aber da fehlt noch ein bisschen was
tja und du war map gucken hier außen weiter laufen
die droppe ansage eigentlich nur wenn er in der nähe tropft oder immer wenn er tropft
wenn einer tropft gute frage nächste frage wenn einer gleichwärts gesniped ja ist er
richtig
M-L-G-Legit
Richtig legit
Okay
Ich revidiere meine Aussagen
Wer hat es fast geschafft zumindest einen wiederzubeleben
Der hat das ist doof gelaufen
Er hat das war warmup
Genau warmup
Aber jetzt seid ihr
Ich such direkt oder?
Jaja
Alles drin außer win
Ah ich hab halt schon gewonnen
Das reicht
Genug pro Tag
Das reicht zwar nicht für Twitch Rivals
Aber für mich reicht
Kommt schon noch
Alter der Dude
Huge sniping skills
Warum war das kein Edge?
Bin ich zu dumm für er?
X-Snipe
So were war das
Okay
Stopping
Ich Russen
X-Night
Ne seh baro, das macht keinen großen Unterschied
Es müsste so ne, so ne Push-to-Mute-Geschichte geben
Dass wenn ich was zum Chat sagen will
Dass ich mich muten kann
Ne, wenn ich zum Chat was sagen will
Dass ich mich muten kann bei euch
Das wäre Poggers
Sag mal, die Schüsse grad durch
Ja, am Ende die letzten 5 Sekunden oder so, da ist äh, ja
Lass mal dreinfliegen
Ok
So
Ja hopp
Jetzt ist ja eigentlich auch irgendwie so ein Trick wie man am schnellsten runterkommt
Also irgendwie erst so ne Kurve fliegen und dann irgendwas ziehen oder
Mir ist noch nichts auf
Ja direkt vor uns
Hinter dir Max ist einer auf dem Dach
Alter
Da müssten noch mehr sein
Ja, da sind ziemlich viele getroppt
Hab einen vor mir
Ja, ich bin gleich da
Brauchen unbedingt Plates
Ich glaub die sind gekördert
Ok
Ja, da hab ich nix dagegen
Was soll ich machen?
Gibt's denn hier noch was?
War der hier schon überall drin?
Wollen wir hier oben den Auftrag dann machen?
Ups
Achso, stimmt
Ja
Man muss bisschen aufpassen, ich weiß noch nicht ob da welche sind
Und den hier?
Obacht geben
Kommt mir nicht durch, ne
Nein, wir brauchen erst nochmal ordentliches Loot
Moving
Spüren kann man sich da ja weniger
Also es geht was, ich hab ordentliches Assault Rifle P90
Paar Platten wäre nicht schlecht
Ganz zu viel
Oh, guck mal hier
Ein Pugger Sniper und ein UAV
Die würde ich mir gönnen
Oder willst du sie?
Ach
Ich hätte hier ne MP7
Legendary
Ja, Dynamisch
Gucken wir was das für eine ist
Na gut, besser als nichts
Ah, guck mal ne M4
Dynamisch
Ja, trotzdem
Ich hab so ne komische Odin
Oder wie auch immer
Die Odin
Vier beste
Und Jungs
Wir können uns einen Loot aufholen
Ok
Wir müssen schlagen, wir laufen nach Richtung By Station
Und dann gönnen wir uns
Ja
Den packen wir nicht mehr bis zum Auftrag
Ich muss kurz umdrehen
Ja
Dann können wir gleich den Auftrag nehmen
Wenn wir eh hier sind
Max, du kannst die andere Schnipser haben
Nö, passt schon
Sniper Rifle hier
Also ich würde vorschlagen
Wir gehen jetzt mal zur By Station
Und dann holen wir uns erstmal einen Loot auf
Sollen wir uns den Auftrag noch annehmen hier?
Das ist vielleicht
Bisschen besser
Aber du kannst die Bounty machen, Max
Ja, meine ich ja
Wo liegt denn das Teil?
Irgendwo
Bei dir
Glaub mir
Wahrscheinlich auf dem Dach
Kann man hier irgendwie hoch?
Alter, wenn ich die Kackhäuser wenigstens kennen würde
in dem Game
Warte mal
Was war für ein Zweifel?
Ich trink 17
Ja, danke
Nö, ok
Dann nicht
Ah
Jetzt wird aber ab zur By Station
Ja
Die sind ja kommt noch
Die sind ja komplett
am Arsch gehört
Dann lass das Auto nehmen
Aber ich fahr
Also ich hab noch eine URV dabei
Sehr schön
Da könnten aber welche sein
Also
Aber gar nicht
Also By Station
ist ja immer bekämpft ohne Ende
Na, es sieht safe aus
Glaub mir mal einer Geld
Dann hol ich noch eine
Huge Buy
Ah, Armour Plate
Gut
So
Nicht erschlagen lassen
Ok, wo ist die?
Fuck
Call of Duty, ich will doch bloß mal ein altes Zeug wieder aufheben
Ok, geht nicht
Genau, das ist das hin vom Loadout
Naja, ich will die Shotgun-Wolfe auch dabei haben
Wieder
Achtung, von wo? Werden wir beschossen?
Ich glaub irgendwo
Ok, die outplayen wir jetzt
Big brain
Outplay
Wow, wow
Von außen links
BTF
Die sind auf der Mauer, geil
Perfekt
Oh man, Alter
Das war auch
Eine richtig big brain Aktion
Ah, meine Güte
Ich bin richtig reingeschissen
Wieder
Richtig dumm
Auch gemacht von ihr
Wer kommt als erstes?
Ich
Der ist da
Der kommt links von dir
Steht so halb im Spawn
Geht in die Mitte, rechts
Ich hab ihn gesehen
Steht noch rechts
Ich muss erstmal retten
Steht an da vorne
Ach scheiße
Ragequit, Alter
Geh mal nicht ums Dachkack-Game
Alter
Scheiße
Kein Bock auf den Kack
Ich hab so verschissen, Alter
Och fuck, die hören mich jetzt ja gar nicht mehr
Wenn ich ragequit-e
Ach scheiße
Oh nee, jetzt hört ihr mich ja gar nicht mehr
Nein, wir hatten eine in-game-Voice
In-game-Voice
Ich hab überhaupt nicht an das Voice-Täusch gedacht, Alter
Oh Mann
Ich ärgere mich bei sowas immer
Aber nicht über meine Mitspieler
Oder so
Sondern einfach weil ich keinen Plan habe
Wie man das richtig spielen muss
Wenn ich nicht irgendjemand dabei hab
Aktuell, der mich bisschen coacht
Und erklärt wo es lang geht
Ich verkacke es voll
Ich hab den Fluss von dem Spielmodus
Noch überhaupt nicht drin
Flur haben wir da eins
Nur WTF
Geil, wir müssen jetzt noch ein paar Runden
Ich muss jetzt noch ein paar Runden
Sinnloses Zeug spielen
Ragequit-e, Alter
Ich muss jetzt irgendwas Sinnloses spielen
Irgendwas total Sinnloses
Nein, WTF
Was kling ich denn da an
Oh, Beste
Ich muss die Musik anmachen
Das ist voll
Das überfordert mich übrigens
Das Game ist neu
Und ich weiß nicht, was ich machen soll
Und wenn ich dann noch
Und dann noch
Mit anderen Leuten
Wo ich keine genaue Ansage kriege
Was, was ist
So
So, das war meine übelsten Rutsche
Oh, warum ist das Game wieder so laut
Stellt sich das
Sag mal
What the hell
Das Game
Haben die Gegner wieder
Chopper gunner
Ach, das ist unsere
Gegner gejohnt
Wo ist der Typ
Achtung
Huge
Okay, der Zapfire
Sagt
Oh
Ups
Ja, der stellt sich bei jedem Leuchter wieder zurück
Ich weiß gar nicht warum
Warum
Total bescheuert
Mega beknackt
Kann man aber bitte in eine Runde
Join, die noch nicht schon angefangen hat
Das ist
Der
By to play
Multiplayer
Aber sicherlich verstehe
Nach wie vor ist
Was ich nicht verstehe ist
Warum man kein Map Voting macht
Hm
Ja, muss Hardcore
Beste Sachen um Waffen zu anlocken
Oh
Ah
Perfekt
Okay, das sah so aus als lebte
Aber kann das sein dass der der schalldämpfer auch den hip spread ein bisschen verkackt
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, BÄÄM
Wobei geht er eigentlich? Ah nee ich wollte gerade sagen ich habe den ich habe den laser weg aber anscheinend habe ich den laser nicht weg
By the way, ich laber grad glaub ich über mein team zu wegen voice chat
Ich glaube das war die ganze voice chat an
Keck W
Warum ich das kot wieder spiele eigentlich weil mir war sounds trio übelspot macht wenn ich
Wenn ich halt jemand dabei habe der mich erstens carried und so weiter wie er das game erklären kann
Ich muss das echt mal lernen ich hab noch nie in battle royale game gespielt
Der ist direkt hinter mir gesporn einfach so
Richtig
Den aber schön c4
Ah meine Ellenbogen tun übelst weh
Das hatte ich schon ewig nicht mehr dass man Ellenbogen weh tun
Neck sie einfach ab ob es dann besser ist
Was ist denn jetzt gerade
In the ass kriegt er geballert
So das war schön meine camp ecke beste
Und irgendwie lässt sich keiner blicken gerade
Hüftgespräche
Ja man stirbt übelst
Wie gesagt der Sinn von hardcore ist ja eigentlich auch dass man schnell stirbt
Beziehungsweise gegner schnell sterben dass man halt mehr kills macht mehr waffenleveln kann ich mache das ja nur zu waffenleveln
Ja das geht mir voll auf den sack wie planlos ich in battle royale spielen bin deswegen crying ich ja jetzt auch gerade ein bisschen
Ich kriege ja sowas meistens halbwegs schnell hin
So halb halbwegs also das braucht dann so einen Monat spielen dann geht es meistens halbwegs
Aber aktuell bin ich voll planlos ich brauche ich bin wirklich trau angewiesen dass wenn man trios spielt dass ich in squadleader dabei hab der was erklären kann
Klusst klusst das ernsthaft
Okay
Lol wie
Das stehen sie in der ecke ich glaube so ist das so ist hardcore gut
So ist hardcore natürlich top ein wilson
Gleich kommt noch der wilson rein
Wo sind denn die gegner überhaupt ah nice down so wilson komm her
Brumm brumm brumm
Brumm brumm brumm ein wilson fährt herum
Was ist das
Ein wilson
Fährt rum
Und auch die gegner
Das ding ist in hardcore extrem op wie man sieht
Das ist ding ist komplett op richtig
Das ding ist komplett op 37 kills
Die gegner kriegen gerade massiv auf den sack
Das ist schon nicht mal feierlich wie die gegner auf den sack kriegen
Noch wilson lol
Der nächste wilson raus
Kek weh alter
Das ist die totale vernichtung
Guckt es euch mal an 52 kills
Massive play of the game huge in eine richtung geschossen
So ist geil youtube video sagste ich weiß nicht das ist eigentlich ziemlich low oder
Ich war ganz davon abgesehen um youtube video zu machen müsst ihr erst mal capturen aber
gut ich hab es ja ich hab es im stream ich hab es ich hab es im stream ja
Ich muss jetzt erst noch mal die guten teamplayer machen
So ich muss mich erst mal entschuldigen für rage quitten ja man gehört sich nicht gehört
sich nicht
Oh ne hab ich da shipment gesehen
Ohje Leute shipment please shipment
Jetzt wirds schlimm jetzt wirds schlimm wir können wir können uns ein VTOL und eine
Wilson ercampen
Das machen wir
Ah shit
Ich hab ne idee ey die beste klasse für diesen shit ist doch wirklich ohne ohne spaß
Leute die beste klasse für den Mist ist doch ach ne man kann keine killstreaks ändern
oder
Ah ne brauchen wir ja auch nicht
Ähm
Hat ma
Edit
Scheißer quick fix wir wollen
Hardline wollen wir haben
Beste
Wir wollen hart wir spielen hartline da kriegen wir den ganzen shit
Da kriegen wir den ganzen shit früher
Ok meine aktuelle kriegen wir gar nichts früher weil wir instant sterben beim spawn
Guckt euch das an alter wie sind das shipment ey shipment
Wir spawnen da einfach hin haben ihr habt das gesehen
Also die map ist absolut unspielbarer shit
Oh sorry sorry sorry
Die map ist wirklich absolut unspielbar
Äh die die loadout shops geschichte find ich auch nicht schlecht
Nicht hinter mir spawn
ALTER MANN GAME
Ah ja ja
Sieht das nicht nach spaß aus leute
Oh mächtig spaß mächtig spaß
Oh Gott
Bitte kein shipment jetzt
Bless rng chat bless rng
Ah mir dämmert grad was als wir eben warzone gespielt haben
Die sind da von links gekommen da war das war ein Auftrag auf uns gell
Das fällt mir jetzt erst auf das hab ich gar nicht realisiert
Da stand ja links das läuft mir jetzt erst ein da stand links auftrag dass sie ein auftrag
auf uns haben und das 3 von 3 ist also sprich dass die eigentlich auch schon da sind
Deswegen war es total bescheuert dass ich da links und rechts rumgehampelt bin
Das hätte ich sehen können hätte ich gesehen dass die gegner irgendwo am start sind direkt
neben uns
Ach nee ach nee schau wieder
Ups was
Es ist wieder shipment
Meine Güte ich will kein shipment spielen
Ich hole mal kurz licht an
Ich kann den filter nein ist das die einzige ist das die einzige map in dem spiel
Ich kann den filter nicht anpassen das sind alle maps in der rotation drinnen unter anderem
shipment also in das ist das ist shoot shoot aus shipment rast und was ist es noch rast
Wahrscheinlich sind nur die drei
Hardcore ground war ah nee
Das beste an dem modus ist ja dass man die waffen schön anlockt schnell anlockt das
haben wir ja mehr oder weniger
Shoot shoot aus ist richtig gut am liebsten würde ich 24 im shoot aus spielen ohne scheiß
shoot aus ist die beste map in dem spiel vielleicht gunrunner noch
Da sitzt er in der hänge und wartet auf mich
Hab ich jetzt eigentlich Hardline ausgerüstet
Es ist alles in der spielmodus in dem spielmodus in der in der liste cancer außer shoot aus
und shoot aus ist äußerst nice
Ames ich dachte ich kann den sprayen
Geh mal auf moab da ist die moab
Da ist die moab
WTF wo sind die alle
Ok letzte runde 57 kills
57 kills easy easy as fuck mal gucken wie das diesmal läuft
Die waffe die pistol
ist so übelst op so geil
So nice
2 versus 2 kann man gleich spielen
Wenn mein anderer kollege da ist mit dem ich sonst immer spiel
aber weiß er das
Dann werden sie wieder gebashed
Das todes
Auf wir sind auch so wir sind nur 4 ok verstehe verstehe easy easy ok so lohnt sich hardcore
natürlich nicht
Ok camp position activated zack
Next zack
Geh los
Oh bist du ok ärztlich schaut
Man kann man da oben hin
In dem moment da oben durchgestellt
Wie kommt man da hin
Bringst die pistol
Mit der pistol macht es übelst bock
Wenn man trifft
Die pistol ist so krass
Das ist so nice
Guckt euch mal aus der hüfte über die ganze map
Habt ihr das gesehen mit der pistol
Wow der macht das gleiche wie ich
Die pistol da brauchst du eigentlich gar keine waffe
Ich spiele jetzt einfach pistol only easy win
I have a pistol only
Ah shit veraimt
Laser pistol das ding ist op oder
Das ding ist echt op
Der Typ da oben geht mir voll auf den kichs
Volle pulle
Da stehen sie
Na ich dachte wir können aus der hüfte sprengen mit der op pistol
Aber ich hab hier sogar stims bei
Es ist verdammt schwer hier killstreaks zu machen
Leute
What the fuck das ist ja
Wisst ihr die ohne scheiß der spielmodus mit einfachen paar guten maps
Und der multiplayer könnte so gut sein
Ups sorry sorry sorry
Schuss weg
Der hat auch die akimbo rennet hier am start
Der ist big brain
Ok wo gehen wir hin
Oder mehr ist der spielmodus
Oder halt die playlist mit gescheiten maps mit ein paar gescheiten maps
Und alles wäre geil
Oh NA what the hell
Den hab ich übelst NA aimed grade
Die spielen halt alle ihre sachen frei
Aber rust ist halt echt cancer
Haha wie der gespreit wurde
Mit der pistole hätte es besser funktioniert
Fliegt man den hardcore raus
Ne du stirbst einfach selbst das haben die ziemlich gut gemacht
Du stirbst du stirbst einfach selbst wenn du zu viel team killst
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich
Moment Moment
Big brain
Gewinnen wir wenigstens
Wir verlieren
Es sagt aber
Na gut
Weil in dieser runde sind keine 57 zu 9 drinne aber trotzdem
Haha keck
Ok wie kommt man da rauf
Vielleicht jetzt eine gute map please
Ah ich dachte es war ich, nee, es war einer mit der gleichen Waffe
Lieber Max, du musst patrouillieren, das lernt man doch im Top 10 tippsten Videos vom Kabu
Verdammt stimmt hätte ich mal dran gedacht und wie geil wäre das wenn das
Spiel so aufgebaut wäre dass man sowas hier noch machen könnte das wäre echt
poggers meine Sätze werden auch immer immer
lowbrainige oder das wäre echt poggers chat finde ich auch dass es echt
poggers wäre nein
nein ich spiele was normales ich muss meinen mein hirn mal wieder einschalten
das problem ist dass alles andere in hardcore halt noch verkämpter ist also
spielen wir eine runde hier wieder hier rege ich mich zwar immer über die maps
auf aber ich finde hier lässt es lässt sich irgendwie noch am angenehmsten
spielen demolition müsste doch glaube auch ganz gut sein oder
demolition ist doch die geschichte mit die csgo lite geschichte mit bomben
legen aber unendlich respawns wenn ich mich noch richtig erinnern kann an den
ganzen kram da wir letzten hat ich letztens ein ziemlich cooles ziemlich
gutes crash gameplay ich glaube auch irgendwie 45 8 oder so rast rast sagt
mal will mich das game eigentlich heute verarschen will mich das game rollen
jetzt kommt ernsthaft rast sprengkommando rast
ok leute wir gehen jetzt aufs dach wo sind sie
was das war andere dute mich erwischt hat rast aller als gäbe es als gäbe es
auf der welt als gäbe es auf der welt nichts anderes mehr super passt ja
keine auf ja da wurde gesporn trappt euch beschütz dich ich beschütze dich
headshot nope jetzt kommen die moves fahk du guckst in die eine richtung mein
gott rast ist eine kacke mehr ok ich bleibe jetzt hier drinnen gekämpft
hat pizzenzer sagt einfach gar nichts obwohl die ganze map voll ist auch geil
was mein team hält nicht aber du kannst dir echt krass sporn trappen immer noch
immer noch immer noch
ist echt so theoretisch jetzt die einmal drinne hier wo ist der typ alter ich war
doch schon um die ecke gibt es noch andere mw2 maps eine gute frage gibt es
noch nee oder ich glaube nicht
oder zwei maps wakant ist gott vier wacant oder wie auch immer die aussprache
ist gott watt reneti tat im halber mich 100 pro war zwar ab ja nee wtf hat die
duzer watt baro rast ja in warzone gibt es jede menge das stimmt
ich mache mir die klasse klar noch mal mit hartlein gerade gerade in so spielmodo
ist hartlein einfach gut weil wenn die hier hier hier gewinnen die kind die
kill streaks halt die games auch watt vor
watt der hell ich habe wheels am start wie toll okay leute jetzt kommt alles
raus scheiß drauf lässt er eine minute jetzt kommt alles raus jetzt kommt alles
raus geben alles
hat mich ziviert das hat er gut gemacht
hast du noch kontakt zum friseur ja klar
wir kannten uns ja vorher schon und wir kennen uns ja immer noch so man kennt
sich halt man kennt sich
ok die runde sind wir wieder ganz gut abgegangen
wer hat gesagt rast ist eine gute map für sprengkommando infinity ward und
infinity ward hat sich sehr viele merkwürdige sachen gedacht in diesem
game wir wollen wieder mit den videos mit dem friseur der friseur der ist
mittlerweile ultra casual geworden der spielt mobile games
der spielt mobile games und das war es mobile games
watt watt der fuck das game du weißt überhaupt nicht vor was kommt er der
ballert hier gleich voll rein ich muss hier hinten halten kommt nix
da section und vor
Meine Güte, kann ich mal sterben.
Wird her, ich stand drei, drei, drei Milliarden Stunden im Gegner spawnen.
What the fuck?
Rust, please!
Deswegen hab ich ein großes Magazin drinnen.
Oh, wie sie reinlaufen.
So macht Call of Duty doch Spaß.
Ah, fuck!
Da werden sie weggebasht, alter.
Guckts euch an! Guckts euch an! Guckts sie euch an! Da werden sie so geschreckt.
Hast du schon was mit Zwift zu tun gehabt? Nee? Ich hab nix mitgemacht.
Die werden so zerstört, so muss das sein.
So mag ich das. Oh fuck. Zwift, ja was ich bisher gesehen hab muss ich sagen, hat's auch
einen guten Eindruck gemacht. Warum kann Call of Duty nicht immer so sein? Einfach, einfach
schnelle Action mit ein bisschen, mit teilweise ein bisschen Sinn verlaufen. So macht es
doch Spaß. So macht es doch Spaß, ey. Demolition, guter Spielmodus. Naja eigentlich nicht,
eigentlich ist Demolition kein guter Spielmodus auf der Map. Meinung zu Unreal Engine 5,
richtig nice.
Okay Leute, ich spiel ein paar 2 on 2s.
Gleich. Ups, oh fuck.
Eins, was ist eins?
Headquarters, Headquarters? Moment, warum?
Sag mal, what the fuck, ich kann nix schreiben auf dem zweiten Bildschirm, ohne dass das
rumspackt. Warum hab ich denn jetzt auf einmal Headquarters? Hab ich nicht gesagt, ich will
Demolition spielen? Ach ne, ich hab mich verklickt, klar ich hab nicht Demolition ausgewählt.
Jetzt erstmal Options, Audio, enabled. Zack, hörst du mich?
Jawoll.
Ja lass mal Ingame Voice machen, ich hab kein TS installiert hier und Discord, können wir
da nachmachen? Discord können wir dann auf irgendeinen, ne wir können auf meinen Discord,
da hab ich ja einen privaten Channel, da könnten wir rein.
Ich hab sonst auch einen Discord.
Ja, können wir da, lass uns mal die Runde mit Ingame Voice machen.
Okay, ich mach dann auf automatische Sekunde.
Ja noch 14 Minuten haben wir noch XP Boost. Jawoll.
So Chet, jetzt kommen die 2 on 2 Kings, no loss heute.
No loss noch nie verloren, soll ich auch streamen machen?
No loss streamen, wenn du willst kannst du machen ja, kann ich dich nicht nachher hosten,
ich mach mal kurz bisschen lauter.
Runde, ich mach mal Licht an, ah wobei eigentlich nicht.
Oh Bazaar, schöne Map.
Tfuck, tfuck.
Ach du bist gerade live, Grüße an alle, hi.
Ja.
X-Greenline Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, huge sup.
So, die Gegner hören uns jetzt nicht oder?
Also.
Äh doch, wenn wir sterben hören die uns.
Aber wir sterben ja nicht.
Ne.
Aber nur kurz oder?
Okay, ich spiel jetzt und mach danach den Stream.
Ja.
Auf gehts.
Ich push mal rechts rum.
Crossbow beste Waffe.
Du?
Okay ich auch.
Okay, dann überrennen wir sie.
Oh, fuck, ich bin down.
Echt, excellent.
Da haben wir wieder die Pros am Start und ich hab nicht Ironsight gemacht, weil ich Battlefield
Kacknoob bin.
Nice, easy win.
Easy, easy, ja gleich, 0 HD holt gleich auf.
Dann wird 0 HD zu 0 4K, dann ist vorbei.
Sollte jetzt Jumpshotten werden.
Oh, fuck, Alter, verengt, Alter.
Einer ist rechts, ja.
Okay, ich brauch gescheite Waffe.
Schön den Kopf geballert.
So, was haben wir denn da jetzt?
Assault Rifle, Kurzvariante.
Einer ist rechts, nee, doch jetzt, mein Gott, Alter, warum treff ich grad nix?
Du machst das schon.
Ja, hier, 403.
links links links ja den arsch geschossen
26 so ein habe ich links
ich flasche ihn ist weg jetzt werde ich hier schon geflammt weil ich nicht den
chat lese während der runde mein gott ich schieß zu schnell mit den kack pistols
besser zielen chat aufwärm runde
meine meinung zu valorant mehr cs als overwatch und zugucken tue ich ganz gerne spieler nicht
hast du schon mal gespielt der rechts hat die kit
ja ich merke es
links ist lau okay
easy clap genau das für ein hässliches ding
ich habe mich mitgekriegt dass darüber gekommen ist
ich habe rechts laser gesehen ich glaube es kämmt einer rechts ich komme ich komme zu
dir einer ist rumgeflankt zu uns hinten die sind nicht schlecht
okay was gibt es jetzt wo ist der andere andere ist rechts hinten
nice 11 der carry ist hart da brennt da brennt easy clap easy clap okay wollen wir kurz abbrechen
und tss discord anmachen ja wir haben schon nächstes game
wollen wir die noch machen oder auch raus
das wirds raus okay
einmal kurz discord an
ich bin einfach direkt am pc gerutscht
oh fuck ich hoffe ich habe nicht den falschen channel auf
wir haben so ein channel das spammen die leute vielleicht komme ich in den händler bildchen
rein das ist schlecht wenn ich den jetzt auf habe im stream
okay moment mein ich bin in welchen kanal muss ich denn
okay
nee wir sind wir sind ich überlege gerade wo sind wir denn du bist gerne bist du general
voice chat
oder ist es jemand anderes
ich bin gerade im stream
ich schreibe dir ich weiß noch nicht vielleicht zu einer halben stunde
ja ja ich ziehe ich ziehe was im laba stelle ich ziehe dich mal hoch
ich seh dich mal kurz so
wie gehen das jetzt gescheit wie kann ich dich jetzt moveen
ah jetzt oder
okay wie funzt das
ja ja ich ich move dich rein
wie gehen das das mag nicht
ah jetzt passt doch
ich glaube jetzt darfst du
gut dann machen wir jetzt mal aus in game
perfekt excellent okay kannst du ich mach dich jetzt noch ein bisschen lauter hier
so jetzt bin ich da ich mach noch mal in game aus
auch guck mal wir haben sogar discord overlay das ist ja voll pro hier
extrem elite
habe ich jetzt ausgemacht push to talk jawoll
ich baale mal schnell mein stream noch an ich hab dein stream gar nicht auf
ja muss ja auch nicht also außer dass es mehr leckt bei dir
ich brauche halt nachteils ich hab gegen keine chance was ich sehs schon
wenn ich stream an hab dann wird das ganz vielleicht zehn prozenten schlechter
encodest du mit der grafikkarte oder machst du über cpu
wahrscheinlich wäre grafikkarte sinnvoll oder
ja ich hab es auch gerade über cpu ich müsste eigentlich auch auf grafikkarte umstellen
fürs spielen
was grafikkarte
encoding
nee auf dich du musst du musst in den settings auf nvn umstellen aber lass erst mal es hat
doch gut funktioniert
gestern
ich hab jetzt auch seit heute 50mb statt 25 upload
ach
was das ganze auch noch einfacher macht
voter phone
voter low
so
ich rede angeblich in game warum das ich hab so ausgeschaltet
open mic hattest
ja
hatte ich
ist das ein bug
hab mein stream jetzt auch mal an
poc
so poc
poc champ meinst du
ja
ich verlinke dich ich verlinke dich mal kurz im chat falls einer aus deiner position sehen
will
dann
der sport stream geht er ist der partner aber dafür brauche ich noch ein paar mehr subs
einer reicht nicht oder wie
nein so mein ich das nicht es hat sich jetzt mal für die übelste flame ein partner reicht
nicht also es reicht nicht
nee nee nee
ich dachte gerade
ja gut bei dem anderen weiß ich ja nicht wie viel es sind
so vielleicht zwei ganz schön mal
ich dachte gerade jetzt kommt der full front du hast zuviel cod nicht gespielt
nee nee
oh gunfight endlich gute map dafür
sepp muller
doch hill geworden ich geh mal raus ich hasse hill du auch
i ja
hill ist die größte kackmap die schlimmste to and to map überhaupt
so mal gucken
pine
shipment hat mich heute fertig gemacht
ich hab waffen gelevelt und stream
ich hab für den stream noch nicht meine ding geändert den filter hab ich noch nicht
reingemacht
weil ich vorher noch nicht die zeit dafür hatte
das heißt wenn der mitruf uns schlecht ist dann tuts mir leid
nee nee das passt
so leute versteht mal alles gut chat
null zuschauer deswegen
alles für die wott
so ich bleib mal links drauf
ich geh direkt hoch in der ersten runde mal gucken was die bekönnen
ich halt mal links und dann geh ich weiter vor
ok links kommt nix
ich wollte um die ecke laufen voll dämlich hängen geblieben
naja
da haben wir gut gemacht
leute ist zu laut oder passt passt die discord lautstärke
links links links links
oder eines links linke seite außen bei in dem spawn
ah die koi big brain
die wollens wissen da
ja leute wieder die übelst geübt haben schon
einer kommt links
ich bin geflasht
nein ich hab der ist im spawn bei uns ich hab grad die waffe geswitcht auf shotgun
oh man das siehts wieder aus
was ich soll ein bisschen lauter machen chat ok
komm das gewinnt man noch
ich muss jetzt auch mal was killen
für 3km so ich bleib gleich links drauf
ich seh links nix
iiii was ist das denn
der ist im smoke drin glaub ich
hier der ist im container unter dir
er hat sich auch gedacht
das ist ja eine übelsträutige waffe hier oder
siehst du links was
das ist wieder hier
das ist das da hast du viel spaß mit
ich lauf mal ich lauf mal vor
fast schon auf 4k hoch fußbeste das ding das ding schickt aber richtig
das war ein treffer oder so er noch gefehlt hat
ich komm noch nicht ganz auf diese mikrolex klar durch stream ich muss echt auf die krakau
umstellen
was denn das
was denn das für ein ding
nee nie
willst du willst du willst du auf grafikkade umstellen
ja das bringt richtig was
ich sag's dir gleich geh mal kurz aus der queue raus du musst eh den stream neu starten
hab ich schon gemacht ich glaube ich hab's kodiere auf ja aber ich glaube da war noch
etwas output ich kann jetzt nicht nach nvn was hast du zur auswahl x 28 x 264 oder software
habe ich und wo kannst du nvn auswählen ja dann ist das das richtige du musst bloß
gucken dass du bitrate und so ordentlich dann hoch stellt habe ich auf markt 320 ich versuch's
mal so wie viel bitrate hast du denn 320 steht da was
nee also bitrate hab ich beim video 5900 das kannst du machen ja ja ich versuch's jetzt
mal das ok
ihr könnt mir ja wenn irgendjemand zuschaut könnt ihr mir gerne sagen kurz ob das funktioniert
ja nur als hilfe ihr müsst doch nicht da bleiben keine angst
ich stream nicht zu festen zeiten aber in letzter zeit relativ häufig tatsächlich ich
hab aber keine festen zeiten es sieht stand jetzt richtig gut aus mit den legs ich hab
da gar nichts ok
ja besser weißt du noch wir mit vodafone vorgestern wo sie erstmal packet loss hatte
erste tag neue leitung und direkt hat es nicht funktioniert danke
gegen chinesische zeichen gegen chinesische zeichen und playstation controller auf geht's
die
Was sagst du, Lul W oder Kek W? Was besser?
Ich sag Lul W. Ja, ich auch. Gut, sind wir uns einig.
Chat, seh dir mal. Lul W für immer.
Lul W ist beste.
Kek W irgendwie. Ich find Lul W geht leichter über die Zunge.
Das stimmt, ja.
Oh, gegen Leg Pain. Leg Pain und abtun.
Sag mal, wir haben echt zu viel gewonnen, oder?
Wir kriegen jetzt nur die mit doppeltem Clan-Tech und übelst so Pro-Names.
Aber wir sind halt einfach zu gut.
Also wir haben ja auch verdammt oft gewonnen die letzten Tage, ne?
Oh, es fühlt sich eindeutig besser an.
Man merkt es leicht, dass Stream an ist.
Aber ich hab auf einmal auch doppelt so viele FPS.
Einer ist glaube ich rechts.
Ach man, einer links im Spawn hinten.
Der ist runtergegangen.
Ah, man kriegt diese Scheiße.
Okay, ich seh' jemand. Warte mal, ist da jemand reingekommen.
So.
Okay, jetzt find ich voll da.
So kann man ja spielen, warum hat mir das niemand früher gesagt?
Niemand sagt mir das.
Ich kann ja mal bei ihm gucken. Oh, oh, oh.
Nice. Ich kann ja mal bei ihm gucken, ob es wenigstens okay aussieht jetzt.
Also Ton wird gefixt in ein bis drei Tagen.
Beziehungsweise relativ bald.
Aber es sollte doch eigentlich gehen, oder?
Ich hab auch auf 60 FPS umgestellt.
Oh fuck, ich hab fett Hit. Linke Seite, Spawn ist einer.
Einer ist dort.
Ich flash mal rüber.
Ja, einer P.
Scheiße.
Ah fuck, nichts gesehen.
Aber jetzt wird der Damage-Stuhl richtig platziert.
Ich muss dieses komische Visier auch mal umschalten.
Ah nee, wir haben eine neue Waffe.
Die 21 Schuss 9mm Pistole.
Einer ist noch links hinten.
Ich flash mal rüber.
Oh Gott.
Ich hab einen Flash gehettet.
Na, einer kommt mit dem Spawn. Ich hab richtig schlecht gespielt.
Einer unter dir.
Links von dir.
Das geht so nicht.
Die machen das clever.
Aber ich bin gerade auch gefühlt richtig lost.
Ja, erst mal warm werden.
Die erste Runde war richtig gut.
Aber sobald es so ist, hat man so vorfühlt.
Ja, rechts einer hier im...
Alter.
Die gehen ab.
Die gehen voll ab.
Okay, ordentliche Waffe.
Ich aim mal rechts ab. Der kommt da bestimmt wieder lang.
Einer ist in der Mitte.
Mitte oben, glaub ich.
Tot.
Wenn wir ein bisschen schimmeln, dann haben wir die.
Ja, ich bleib hinten.
Bleib mal bei dir einfach.
Ich guck mal links.
Okay.
Okay, ich peek jetzt gleich mal hier aus dem Spawn raus. Mal gucken.
Einer hat gut hit.
LulHD.
Der zeigt nur rot an, wenn man Headshot Kill macht, oder?
Weil das davor waren auch welche.
Sonst hätte es irgendwie auf keinen Sinn ergibt.
Einer links in der Mitte.
Fuck.
So langsam wird es aber echt schwierig, ja.
Ja, ist echt so, oder?
Okay, okay.
Okay, ich glaube der eine pusht rechts lang.
Einer oben, hab ihn.
Wo ist der oben oder unten?
Unten rechts im Container.
Was ist das für eine Waffe? Der kommt jetzt durch.
Chat, ich sack voll mit der Waffe.
Jetzt hab ich ihn verloren.
Versteckt.
Ah, shit.
Ich hab zweimal voll vorbei geschossen, weil ich gedacht hab, das Ding schießt schneller, als es letztendlich geschossen hat.
Aber wie kam er da so schnell raus und nach oben?
Okay, und Shotgun?
Und Pistole.
Hoch mit drauf. Zwei Shotgun ist richtig scheiße.
Ah, shit.
Einer war hinten rechts.
Einer schon.
Was für hinten rechts?
Egal, Aufwärme, Aufwärme.
Echt so. Hat niemand gesehen, tut eh keiner zu.
Scheiße.
You know what? Brexit is good.
Jetzt werden sie geflamed.
Ich hör die gar nicht. Ich hab das aus. Ich hab das komplett. Ich will das Gelaber gar nicht hören.
Er hat gesagt, you know what? You guys are shit.
You know what? Brexit was good.
Lohnt sich XP boostbar 2 on 2? Nee, oder?
Also, theoretisch lohnt sich das überall, aber...
Ach Tom. Nee, mach schon den anderen.
Ich hab halt noch eins, vier...
Wieder Playstation.
Ich hab halt elf Stück, deswegen...
Ja, man gewöhnt sich an diese leichten Legs beim Spielen.
Docs, Scheidemap.
Das ist so leicht.
Sollte aber eigentlich spätestens wenn...
Hast du OBS offen oder minimiert?
Ja, hab ich oft. Soll ich minimieren?
Mach mal minimiert, ja. Weiß nie so genau.
Dann seh ich halt 100% nicht...
Das kann aber echt sein.
Weil dann seh ich halt...
Boah, wenn das das jetzt ist...
Ich hab keinen Chat auf und sowas.
Außer auf dem Handy links neben mir, deswegen...
Falls jemand was schreibt. Hi.
Komm, ich push jetzt mal rechts oben durch.
Oder willst du?
Du hast recht, es gibt gar keinen Leg mehr seitdem es zu ist.
Und uns.
Komm mal zurück.
Da ist einer drin.
Ich muss gucken, dass der andere nicht von hinten kommt.
Down.
Wo ist der andere? Okay, hat der im Spawn gestanden?
Weiß nicht, aber...
Ja, doch.
Ja, gut.
Hey, aber wenn OBS minimiert ist, ist alles weg.
Dann ist doch nice. Dann kannst du jetzt Hardcore carryen.
Das wird gemacht, Chef.
Boah, ich werd von zwei Seiten gehen. Nein!
Ah, zum Glück hat er ne Flash.
Alter, warum sack ich grad so? Das ist ja Hardcore, ey.
Kein LowHD.
Vor allem kein 4K.
Der hatte schon, der andere ist voll.
Ah, ist das Auto in die Luft geflogen?
Topkick.
Das hat er aber gut gemacht. Nice, Nate.
Das ist diese Sniper, egal.
Also links seh ich nix.
Zack. Ja, mein Helft ist schön.
Letzte.
Ich glaub, der ist rechts hier drinnen bei mir.
Ich hör den.
Oben und unten?
Der kommt, glaub ich, grad hoch.
Tatsächlich, hol ihn dir.
Jawollo, schöne bait und switch.
Das haben wir schön abgesprungen.
Ich muss mehr Iron Sides machen. Ich hab echt so dieses Battlefield-Ding.
Hüfte Pistole.
Rechts ist einer im Spawn hinten.
Einer ist oben.
Ich komm mal mit zu dir hoch.
Wollen wir aimen, dass keiner rüberkommt.
Ich hab mir gerade so einen Halfshot rein, aber unten ist er.
Wo gehst du denn hin, Kumpel?
Oh, der andere ist auch noch hinten.
Habt ihr noch einen Halfshot rein?
Ich geh unten an die Tür.
Oben ist ich bei ihm im Spawn.
Ich nehm einen oder lass mal einen.
So geht's.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wo er abgedampft ist.
Flitz, flitz, flitz.
Ja, ja, ja, hast du ja recht.
Ist der burst?
Ja.
Einer geht links oben und einer geht rechts.
Woah.
Across map headshotted.
Einer rechts hinten, weil sie in dem Spawn, einer ist links hochgegangen.
Nice.
Ich hab ihn einfach...
Hey, ich hab ihn einfach fast across the map gefroren.
Ich liebe dieses Spiel.
Aber die Waffe ist echt richtig krass.
Ich hab ihn gefroren einfach.
Oh, einer im Spawn.
Scheiße.
Ich geh oben ans Fenster.
Ja, ich hab 50 HP.
Einer hat Hit auf der linken Seite außen.
Danke.
Okay, ich hab niemand getroffen diesmal.
Einen hab ich.
Schön, ich hab floor HP.
Er kommt hier unten, glaub ich.
Ja.
Nice.
Hast du gerade nahe gekämpft?
Nee, nee, aber fast.
Ah, geschotgunned.
Bam.
Also, wenn das kein one hit ist, was dann?
Well played, dudes.
Nee, einer noch.
Ich hab den trotzdem schon mal.
Die spielen uns echt nicht schlecht.
Die sind, glaub ich, alle beide links gegangen.
Was ist denn das für ein blauer Laser?
Noch nie gesehen.
Irgendso ein Sting.
Ach, das sind Tracer.
Oh mein Gott.
Wo war er?
Links oben im Haus.
Du kannst auch Shift drücken, dann hast du Ironsight.
Aber lohnt sich nicht so.
Er hat 30 HP.
Du hast schon Molotov.
Viel zu hoch.
Ja.
Er weiß, wo du hin gehst.
Der letzte sollte an der Flagge sein, ungefähr.
Aber kein Safe Call.
Wenn er jetzt...
Er hat gerade eine Hitmarke bekommen, oder?
Hol sie, hol sie, die Flagge.
Jawoll.
Ich hab eine Hitmarke bekommen.
Ich wusste aber null, wo er ist.
Im Auto war der wahrscheinlich.
So, Win.
So muss es sein.
GG.
420 Damage.
Oh, das ist ja was.
Wenn wir jetzt noch 69 Damage hätten,
hätten wir die ganzen Beam-Damage-Zahlen durch.
Dann hätten wir aber nicht gewonnen.
Das ist wohl wahr, ja.
669 wäre auch okay.
Shipman klebt an mir.
Ja, ich sehe es, wie Hill an dir klebt.
Sollen wir?
Ja, komm.
Sind das die gleichen von eben?
Ja.
Das ist die größte Scheiß-Map in diesem Spielmodus.
Der eine ist raus.
Ich glaube eher, dass er noch connected.
Die müssen ja zusammengesucht haben.
Der wird jetzt ja nicht sein Mate einfach lassen, oder?
Oder doch?
Weiß nicht.
Nein.
Ich dachte schon.
Drauf.
Da war einfach volle Kanne drauf, aber zählt nicht.
Einer hat Hit.
Einer ist hinter mir irgendwo.
Oh fuck.
Der andere war glaube ich hinter mir her.
Alter, ich komme nicht klar.
Der ist ganz rechts außen.
Ganz rechts außen war der.
Da, da wo du hinguckst.
Da, irgendwo da.
Nice.
Ich habe den anderen einfach geschlagen, als er auf dem Boden war.
Komm, wir pushen da jetzt mal durch.
Ja, klar.
Rechts, rechts ist einer.
Hier steht auch einer in der Mitte.
Hat dich, hat gut Hit.
Ich sehe ihn nicht.
Am Turm, am Turm, am Turm war der.
Ich bin im Swan, ich bin im Swan.
Ah ja, ich sehe ihn.
Einer dürfte down sein.
Ja.
End.
Schön, du HD.
Pass mal auf.
Hüfte.
Aber aus der Entfernung geht das, oder?
Gegen gute Gegner nicht.
Ja.
Deine beste Waffe.
Was haben wir denn da?
Ah, beste.
Beide im Spawn hinten haben gut Hit.
Ja, okay, der eine hat mich gepre-aimt.
Da kann ich leider nichts machen.
Wow.
Fuck.
Machst du.
Wir haben beide, beide one Hit.
Du hattest einen HP.
Ja, fuck.
Noch mal?
Gleicher.
Was ist das für eine Shotgun?
Ist die auf Long Range?
Ich sehe nichts.
Wir werden wahrscheinlich im Spawn campen,
weil wir immer drauf gerannt sind.
Ich werfe mal, ich werfe mal ganz hinten den Spawn.
Nee?
Nichts erwischt.
Ich sehe absolut niemand.
Ich lege mich mal hin.
Auch nicht.
Ich gucke mal nach links, also.
Ah, ich sehe einen Linz laufen.
Linz im Wald.
Ich push mal links rüber.
Nice, nice.
Ich habe ihn gesehen, wie er umgecapped ist.
Der andere ist hinter mir.
Der war direkt hinter mir.
Ach, meine Fresse.
Warum spinne ich so scheiße gerade?
Warum kämpfe ich überhaupt gegen den in dieser Scheißpose hier?
Richtig bescheuert.
Ich bin am Felsen, da kann ich ja nicht großartig was machen.
Einsicht ist der erste Weg.
Ja.
Meine Mutter immer.
Einer an dem.
Ich flasche mal rüber.
Ich habe schon einen richtig dicken Hit drin.
Ich auch.
Aber der andere hat 50 HP.
Hab ihn.
Oh, doch.
Weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich schleiche mal ein bisschen.
50 HP.
Hast du geflasht?
Nee.
Wow.
Der ist von links gekommen, der Molotov.
Von links eingeflogen.
Hinten oder was?
Da wo der Turm ist.
Von unserem Spawn aus links.
Am Turm, ja.
Ja, ja.
Turm ist das Einzige, was ich da merken kann.
Ich schiebe es mal auf die Map.
Ja, ja.
Ich habe gerade die Offenbarung, wie es einfach gut läuft.
Beide rechts, habe keine Chance gegen zwei.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was meine Shortcuts zum Distrobuten sind.
Beide waren vorher da rechts, ja.
Rechts vielleicht schon, ja.
Schön.
Da ist mehr HP.
Aber oben, der über...
Fuck man.
Was du noch üben musst, ist, wenn du angeschossen wirst, dass du nicht wie so ein aufgescheuchtes
Reh einfach in Schusslinie wegrennst.
Direkt hinlegen oder weg irgendwie so zur Seite, dass der volle Schuss fällt.
Scheiße.
Ah, helfst ihm.
Bist du, guckst du links?
Einer läuft links.
Ich habe links lang laufen sehen.
Ich sehe nicht links.
Ich sehe halt echt niemand.
Einer ist im Spawn hinten, linke Seite von dir.
Ah, scheiße.
Voll in dir.
Jawoll.
Halt.
Oh Gott.
Warum sehe ich so eine Scheiße nicht?
Vielleicht bin ich zu lang schon on, ey.
Ich bin fast sechs Stunden on wieder.
Echt?
Ja.
Oha.
Ich tue echt.
Wer hält das denn sechs Stunden aus?
Wir machen Granat.
Wir machen NoobTube.
Ey, wir gewinnen jetzt erst mal.
Klar.
Only wins.
Ich nade ihn mal tot.
Okay, hab nicht geglaubt.
Ah, da.
Wo ist denn der?
Im Spawn?
Hinter dem Truck im Spawn.
Ich sehe aber nicht, wo er ist.
Er wirft was.
Geh hinter dem Truck, guck ich jetzt.
Ah, ich sehe ihn.
Okay, nice.
Den haben wir.
Jetzt guck mal an, wie ich ihn bisschen disrespected habe.
Im Arsch.
Okay, okay.
Ich geh mal wieder ganz rechts.
Und, zack.
Hier rechts...
Oh Mann!
Rechts ist er.
Einer!
Einer.
Der hat aber auch schon Hit drin.
Genau, der hat schon Treffer drin.
Minus 30, das ist halt Schmutz mit Küste.
Haha, oh Mann. Da wird hard carried.
Das hat er sich ja noch vorgestellt.
Ja, ich höre immer diese Kommunikation von denen.
Du sagst so, ja der hat schon hinten, der hat schon hinten.
Matchpoint, das sind Liritholen.
Links könnte dumm sein, aber lass mal da smokeen.
Da kommen die throwing naves schon.
Smoke mal da ab, vielleicht können wir dann hochgehen.
Ich versuch's einfach mal.
Was solls.
Ich renn einfach mal durch und spawn.
Ich guck nicht, ob die da sind.
Ich hab rechts geguckt.
Ich will mal den spawnen, hinter ihm.
Hinter ihm.
Yo, what the fuck sagt der.
Ich weiß aber nicht, wo der andere ist.
Links, links am Wall.
Ich wollt die mit dem throwing einfach werfen, weil ich so arrogant bin.
Aber du da, die macht das.
Das war echt arrogant.
Next.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man das sechs Stunden aushält.
Chat, keine Ahnung, wie hab ich das gemacht.
Es waren ein paar richtig coole normale Multiplayer-Games dabei.
Sollen wir weiterspielen?
Ja, ja.
Wir können ruhig noch ein bisschen.
So eine halbe Stunde oder so krieg ich noch hin.
Also man muss ja sagen, Rust.
Was war das?
Ich glaub Rust Demolition Hardcore.
Oder was war das?
Ich krieg's immer zusammen.
Das war übelst, übelst krass.
Wie toll.
Doppel Wield sind am Start.
Und innerhalb von irgendwie einer halben Minute 40 Kills.
Das war unnormal.
Warum ist eigentlich nur mit Shoot-Horse nur eine gescheite Web in dieser Rotation?
Ist noch da?
Ja klar.
Ich hab gerade nur ganz kurz mein Reallife gecheckt.
Was?
Ist das eine Ball-Action?
Ja, ja klar.
Links guckt einer.
Okay.
Aber wo?
Jetzt zwei.
Ah, da.
Ah, okay.
Da kommt er gehüpft.
Okay, das weiß ich, ob wir das gleiche nochmal machen können.
Ich guck mal rechts wieder.
Naja, rechts guckt einer.
Links verschimmt dann auch wieder.
Weiß nicht.
Ich aim die Mitte.
Was haben wir denn?
Flash, Flamer.
Links bei uns ist, auf der linken Seite war was.
Wenn ihr spawnen, sind wir spawnen.
Fuck.
War das schon da?
Ja.
Der hat richtig shit einen Pistolen-Treffer noch.
Aber sicher noch den Headshot hinterherhauen.
Muss.
Okay, was haben wir?
MP5.
Okay, was haben wir mit MP5?
Ich stelle mich mal aufs Waschbecken.
Ob ich da irgendwo einen sehe, auf der linken Seite oder so.
Ah, der eine ist in der Mitte.
Was haben wir denn da?
Das ist Morp.
Uiuiuiuiuiui.
Was hab ich denn gerade für Hits bekommen?
Ich hab acht HP.
Einer war rechts.
Oh.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Du musst dich ein bisschen carryen, ich hab low.
Shit.
Die haben echt zu viel gewonnen.
Die Gegner sind mittlerweile viel schwerer.
Oder ich kriege halt nichts mehr gebacken.
Eins von beiden.
Die haben mich gerade falsch gewusst, aber die sind nicht gut.
Ich stelle mich mal wieder aufs Waschbecken.
Das war, ich glaube, nicht schlecht.
Die sind echt nicht so gut.
Wenn du mir sagst, ich hab...
Nee, ich weiß nicht.
Ah, im Mitte, im Mitte spawnen.
Bei denen.
Oha.
Links im Spawn.
Fuck, rechts, rechte Seite bei ihnen im Spawn.
Ey, mit mir kannst du ja nix mehr anfangen.
Da oben ist er.
Ah, schön.
Oh.
What?
Kann er mal sterben?
Ich hatte fünf HP, gell?
Ja.
Ey, glaub...
Aber hast richtig nice gehauen.
Weg mit dem Dreck.
Okay, Autospotgun.
Einer hat nen Hit in der Mitte.
Er kommt close.
Ich glaub's nicht, ey.
Ich glaub, ich muss aufhören.
Nein, du machst das.
Easy.
Ich kann direkt sterben, kein Problem.
Easy win.
Nee, aber mit mir kannst du grad echt nix mehr anfangen.
Ich steh da, guck um die Ecke, bam, tot.
Ohne, dass ich irgendwie checken würde, was passiert.
Und die Leute schon nicht mal in gutem Gameplay zuhören, das ist echt traurig.
Der rechts hat ganz gute Hits.
In der Mitte war einer.
Oh, fuck.
Einer steht noch in der Mitte.
Hat auch wieder Hit drinne.
Andere Seite.
Chat, give energy.
Wir müssen diese Scheiße noch gewinnen.
Sonst kann ich nicht richtig pennen nachher.
Ist das Auto?
Ja, das Noobtuch.
Mach dein Raket, wir fahren.
Und...
Bumm.
Okay.
Scheiße.
Mein Gott, ich krieg nix gebacken.
Schlimm, schlimm, schlimm, schlimm.
Boah, ist nicht schlecht.
Oh nein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ah, fuck.
Die hat jemand geholt?
Der Chat, der Chat, gift energy.
Jetzt, jetzt müssen wir gewinnen.
Ich hab immer noch keine einzige Nachricht in meinem Chat heute.
Chat, das kann auch nicht sein.
Nein.
Ist ja egal.
Okay, ich guck links.
Ist nix da.
Ah, ist unten.
Okay, einer ist weg.
Aber einer war rechts noch im Spawn.
Einer ist in der Mitte, einer ist in der Mitte.
Hab ich ihn gerade rausgucken sehen.
Das war nicht die Mitte.
Der war rechts.
Dann ist er wieder rüber.
Wie heißt der Kanal von dem Dude hier?
So.
Wettretz sowie Inge.
Einer hat links hit.
Ich aber auch.
Ja, du aber.
Oh nein, nein, nein.
Einer ist rechts.
Ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Alarm ist, aber ich glaube, dass es Follow ist.
Danke.
Jetzt hab ich grad Absolutenz.
Krust ist aus.
Rechts.
Ah, fuck, eins.
Kumpel.
Eins, eins.
Da ist er.
Rechts.
Jawoll.
Ja.
Ich kann mich hier nicht muten.
Sorry, sonst würd ich mich muten.
Nee, nee, passt schon.
Ich kann ihm ruhig ein paar Follows dalassen.
Irgendeiner muss mich ja carryen.
Ich hatte 69 Follows.
Einer war rechts.
Ich wollte nur Abos.
Was?
Einer links.
Krass.
So cocky sind wir dann auch nicht.
War einer in der Mitte?
Oh Gott.
Okay, einer hat gut Granaten.
Ich hab hier diese Pistols auf diese Distanz.
Die sind so unreliable.
Kann der links kommen?
Ja, ja.
Hat 20 HP.
Da kann man jetzt aber aus der Hüfte schießen beim Slideren.
Slidorino.
Das ist mein echtes Vorbild.
Du rutschst so über den Boden und dann schießt er rein.
Vor allem noch den Gangster-Style.
Nicht irgendwie nach oben, sondern schräg.
Wir haben hier gewonnen.
Wir planen hier auch was.
Flur haben wir jetzt.
2-2-6-3.
Eins können wir noch spielen.
Das müssen wir jetzt auch gewinnen, Chat.
Ich penn.
Ich hoffe euch hat's gefallen.
Auch wenn heute...
Ich hab versucht, mit zwei anderen Kollegen Battle Royale zu spielen.
Voll verschissen.
Ich hab dann...
Du brauchst halt gute Kollegen.
Nee, ich glaub, die sind gar nicht so übel.
Aber ich hab das Problem.
Okay.
Ich hab noch so keinen Plan von dem Spielmodus.
Wenn ich keinen dabei hab, der ein bisschen Ansage macht, wohin und was wir als nächstes
machen.
Ich renne voll planlos rum.
Deswegen klappt das ja auch so ganz gut.
Weißt du, wenn du sagst, wir gehen jetzt da rein, dann machen wir jetzt hier erstmal
nichts.
Das kommt halt von CS richtig viel.
Da kann man root callen.
Ich hoffe mal, dass das alles funktioniert.
Hast du gerade Urlaub oder warum streamst du so viel?
Tja.
Oh, ich muss ja morgen arbeiten.
Fuck.
Ja, ich muss dann echt pennen.
Oh, Rust.
Beste.
Elf Zuschauer.
Hi.
Wenn ich einen 75 Zuschauer-Ausschnitt hab, dann können wir einen Spot streamen.
Dann bin ich warten.
Aber...
Da muss noch eindeutig mehr Content kommen.
Willst du danach weiter streamen?
Oder ist dann Schluss?
Ich glaub, ich spiel was und danach noch ein bisschen.
Dann raiden wir dich danach.
So, mal gucken.
Wo sind sie?
Oh, ich bin einfach destruct.
Oben vielleicht?
Nee, ich bin auf dem Rohr.
Auf dem Rohr oben bin ich.
Du musst einmal kurz nachladen.
Ich geh mal hoch.
Der ist hinten.
Was ist denn das?
Der Durchgang zur...
Ich töt' ihn einfach, dann soll ich dir wohl über...
Wow.
Ach, hier hinten.
Am roten Container.
Das ist echt eine Frau.
Ich wollte eigentlich Takedown machen, aber dann dachte ich so...
Gehört sich nicht.
Ich hör's nicht bei Frauen.
Mal links gucken, ob da was kommt.
Ich geh direkt hoch.
Okay, ich seh nix.
Ah, ich seh ihn hinten.
Ich geh mal links durch wieder.
Der ist gehittet oben, sagt die.
Hi.
Heirate mich.
Was?
Einer ist über mir, eventuell.
Ich hab's nicht gehört.
Oh, es gibt auch noch Schaden.
Oh, fuck.
Wo ist er?
Irgendwo oben, oder?
Weiß nicht.
Wir können einfach einnehmen, klar.
Oh, ich wurde von links gehittet irgendwo.
Was ist links?
Ja, ja.
Da, da.
Durchslide, Durchslide-Ding.
Ich nehm' einen.
Pass auf.
Hüften, Hüftigeballer.
Ich wollt' ihn schlagen, aber ich hätt' keine Dinger mehr.
Trepp mal high rein.
Oh, beste, beste.
Waffe.
Ich guck' links, ob was kommt.
Ich seh' nix.
Einer ist hier oben auf dem Tisch.
Ich geh' mal rauf.
Einer rennt auf der B-Flagge gerade.
Okay.
Ey, ich kann's vergessen.
Ich krieg' heut' nix mehr gebacken.
Ah, wir haben Hälfte.
Copper.
Adil.
Ich krieg' heut' nix mehr hin.
Ey, ich treff' nix.
Vergiss es nicht.
Du musst an dich glauben.
Ja, nach 6 Stunden klappt's aber nicht mehr.
Also, ich kann an mich glauben, aber ey, ich treff' nix mehr.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
Mir tun übelst die Ellenbogen weh, seitdem ich wieder so viel spiele.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Eine Runde.
Ja, easy win.
Was heißt hier 0W?
Ich seh' nix.
Ich seh' gar keinen.
Ich renn' mal zu denen und spawn.
Ich mach's einfach.
Oh.
Down.
Das ist so geil.
Hier ist einer oben.
Oben in der Mitte.
In der Mitte ist er drin.
In diesem Gerüst unten.
Unten im Gerüst irgendwo.
Ah, ich weiß nicht, was du meinst.
What?
Wo ist der denn so schnell hin?
Der ist glaub' bei uns hinten im Spawn.
Irgendwo da.
Egal.
Wie ist der denn so schnell da hingekommen?
Ich schreib' mal sorry für erschrecken.
Der hat's richtig gesprüht.
The Golden Dragon Arca-Soviet.
Geil.
Der sieht ja mal brutal geil aus.
Warum hab ich denn diesen Stun nicht?
Ich würd' den direkt kaufen.
Wo?
Im Container in der Mitte.
0W.
Ich schreib' Madden-Chat.
Die hat ja sogar ein Messer vorne dran.
Ist das nur Show oder macht das dann wirklich One Hit?
One Hit.
Aber die Goldene Arca mit Granatwerfer und mit Drum-Mack.
Okay.
Und ich bin dämlich runtergesprungen.
Ich bin runtergesprungen und hab' Leertaste für Fallschirm gedrückt.
Was irgendwie nicht so ganz funktioniert.
Ja.
Sag' ihm doch mal Callouts.
Mann.
Er sagt, du bist ganz heftig dumm.
Du kannst mich mal Callouts geben.
Daran wird's liegen.
Ach, sind das Deutsche?
Ja, das ist ne deutsche Frau.
Die trifft ja gar nichts.
Aber gar nichts.
Der ist oben in der Mitte, ne?
Okay.
Hat Spaß gemacht.
Ich muss jetzt noch mal sagen.
Ich sag' dir jetzt mal was.
Es ist halt auch schwer, wenn du nichts Calls.
Mann, call ihr doch mal nächstes Mal.
Dann flamen die doch nicht.
Die trennen sich gleich an installen, was auch immer.
Nein, die haben gelacht.
Weiß ja nicht.
Toxic Chat, Alter.
Äh, nicht Toxic Chat.
Toxic Voice.
Nee, es war nur nett gemeint, wenn du sagst, du callst mir nie.
Ich sterb immer.
Ach, so rum?
Ich dachte, er beschwert sich.
Nein.
Und sie hat sich beschwert.
Dann sag' ich so, man, du callst ja halt auch nie.
Ja.
Das war ne Sauerei.
Ach ja.
Das ist ja geil, dass sie immer erzählt, er muss callen.
Ich edit' die mal beide.
Ich fand's lustig.
Das ist doch cool.
Oh, fuck.
Ja gut, müssen wir jetzt noch spielen.
Ach so, ja.
Wir können auch aufrichten.
Nee, lasst's kommen, wir haben aber noch.
Bazaar ist ein guter Map.
Bazaar.
Easy Clap.
Ich brauch' auch so...
Wo hast du das gebeindet, oder hast du irgendwelche extra Tears für deine schönen GIFs, die
immer reinfliegen?
Das ist was, was ich selbst programmiert hab.
Das sind Webinterfails auf dem zweiten Rechner.
Da kann man das einfach anklicken.
Scheiße.
Big Brain.
Oh, jetzt kommt...
Einer ist links rum.
Wow.
Oh, einer ist oben.
Und ich wurde gehittert.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Du weißt, was heißt, wenn wir verlieren was?
Dann kann ich nicht ins Bett, oder was?
Ja.
Wir hätten's einfach dabei lassen sollen, ja.
Nee, nee, nee.
Easy.
Chat.
Energy.
Oh, einer ist down.
Einer ist noch hinten im Spawn bei denen.
Ich hab halt...
Du hast mehr.
Was?
Hä?
Ich hab's gesehen.
Du warst direkt drauf.
Aber diese Diesel ist halt einfach auch scheiße.
Hä?
Reudische Waffe.
Wann hab ich denn in die Wand geguckt?
Hab ich irgendwas verpasst?
Also, ich hab's bei dir auch so gesehen.
Deshalb warst voll drauf.
Null zu zwei.
Nie mehr wieder werde ich das machen.
Die Frage wird oben sein, vergiss nicht.
Jawoll, Lula D hat das immer.
Ich mein, Max und Moritz muss ja ein gutes Team sein.
Ach du hast Moritz?
Ja klar.
Das ist ja nice, das passt richtig gut.
Okay, rechts ist nix.
Einer oben, einer kommt mit Schottland.
Beide, beide.
Ah, der kommt her.
Achtung, du musst vielleicht hin.
Der hat Hit.
Jawoll.
Lulvee PogChamp.
Bumm.
Stabile Uhr.
Ist die iced out.
Das ist die Default Uhr.
Es gibt keine Default Uhr.
Echt nicht?
Okay, einer war links.
Oben, einer ist oben in der Mitte.
Der kommt zu dir gepusht.
Ich bin bei dir.
Achso, ich dachte du bist rechts.
Ich war rechts.
Ich hab einfach mit dem C4 wieder 40 Schaden.
Lustig.
Ey, danke für diesen Tipp mit OBS minimieren.
Das ist zwar so simpel, aber...
Läuft es jetzt besser?
Es läuft, als wenn ich nicht stream.
Ich seh nix, ich tu nur so.
Als bin ich kack oben.
Da ist C4 hintergeflogen gekommen.
Ich hab mega die Hits bekommen.
Ach man links nur deine Spawn.
Hol den dir.
Huge Play.
Ich hab 400 Schaden und einen Kill.
Das ist eine gute Frage.
In Wien war so 4000 Schaden und 5 Kills.
Der Tipp mit OBS war einfach minimieren.
Ich hab nie so viel Internet.
Hinten ist einer.
Bei dir kommt einer.
Okay, passt.
A noch oben bei dir.
Der hat Fat Hit, der ist noch drin.
Der guckt in deine Richtung.
Nice.
So, 2 Runden noch.
Er sagt alle, weil alle Leute, die müssen Internet fixen.
Aber die haben einfach 160 der Ping.
Ich tu nur so, als halte ich da rein.
Ich hab nämlich nix gesehen.
Ich komm mal zu dir rüber.
Hab ich einen Hit bekommen links?
Hab ich einen Hit bekommen?
Ich hab eines schon zu früh geernt und...
Das könnte sein, dass der uns auch komplett geflankt hat.
Ich glaub, ich nehm mich auch.
Okay.
So kann es auch gehen.
Moist.
Ich schreib eins zurück, was ihn nervt.
QQ.
Okay, was ist das für ein Ding?
Nein.
Ich hab einen Hit.
Der ist links im Spawn.
Ich hab's, warte.
Er schießt halt vor.
Der andere geht.
2 gegen 1 für die letzte Runde.
Ach, der ist gelieft?
Warum? Ist der blöd?
Der dachte, er ist vorbei.
Lass ihn mal zusammenpeaken.
Er kann uns nicht beide holen.
Er rennt rechts hoch.
Hier oben ist er.
Alter.
What the hell?
Wir verlieren jetzt nicht gegen einen.
Wir gehen nach dem, was für eine Waffe kommt.
Gib mir eine.
Egal, das Zusammenlaufen hat gar keine Chance.
Hier oben, wir dürfen nicht zusammenpeaken.
Wir dürfen das machen, was sie...
Er ist nicht bei uns, dann ist er auf der anderen Seite.
Ah, hier ist er oben.
Oha, was er trifft.
Wo ist er?
Er ist bei sich hochgegangen.
Der ist oben.
Der ist einfach so.
Der kommt runter.
Links oder rechts?
Ich glaube eher links.
Jawoll, der hat 20 HP.
Muss hinter dem Ding sein.
Alter.
Wir haben das jetzt verloren gegen einen.
Was sollst du machen?
Erstens hat der Chat keine Energy gegeben.
Und zweitens habe ich ihn nicht getroffen.
Und zweitens macht er 15.000 Schaden heil.
15.000 Schaden heil.
Wie kann man das verlieren, der WTF?
Was haben wir da jetzt?
Verkackt, Alter.
Was haben wir? 22 Uhr, wir müssen noch ein Spiel.
Wir müssen noch gewinnen.
Oder wollen wir Schluss machen?
Doch, doch.
Ich werde auch danach noch eine Runde Warzone spielen,
weil ich es meinem Kollegen versprochen habe.
Dann machen wir jetzt noch eine Runde, es geht bis 23 Uhr.
Dann haust du dich oder ich raide dich.
Oder was auch immer.
Und dann bleibt jeder einzelne da, bis ich schlafe.
Genau.
Wir können ja immer abwechselnd 6 Stunden streamen.
Wir können immer einer 6 Stunden schlafen.
Beste Idee. Und wann gehen wir arbeiten?
Das ist overrated.
Wir können auch einmal 6 Stunden arbeiten.
Wir arbeiten eh nicht mehr.
Einfach einchecken.
Homeoffice startet und dann spenden.
So was machen wir nicht.
Nein, das würden wir nie machen.
Arbeiten LULW, der Chat.
Das Ding ist, wenn der Chat
10 Mal mehr wäre, dann müsste man nicht mehr arbeiten.
Ich glaube, wir hätten das eben ein bisschen defensiver spielen müssen.
Was hätte er machen sollen? Großartig.
Spätestens, wenn die Flagge kommt, hätten wir gewonnen.
Die Frau hat mich angenommen.
Foggers.
Vielleicht heiratet ihr.
Einer ist im Spot.
Und einer pusht in der Mitte links, glaube ich.
Einer pulst, geiler kommt.
Mitte, Mitte, Mitte hat Hit.
Was ist Mitte bei dir?
Auf dem Ding oben drauf.
Ich verstehe diese Mechanik nicht.
Wie er schneller schießen kann, obwohl er slidet.
Wo ist er denn?
Er weiß dahin, dass er slidet. Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich treffe nichts mehr.
Es ist wirklich schlimm.
Ich habe echt zu lange gespielt.
Da kann man hoch. Ja, Chat.
Anscheinend.
Über dir einer, über dir einer.
Die schießen schneller, als man überhaupt mit Maus schießen kann.
Der abschirmt hier den Trigger an Bord.
Ne, also mit Kontrolle.
Geht das? Ne, oder?
Doch, doch, doch. Das geht mir schon.
Du kannst so schnell, wie du drücken kannst, schießen.
Was ist denn das, Alter?
Ich habe gerade voll reingedrückt.
Vor allem mit einem fucking Controller.
Da ist rechts, oder?
Ja, Chat, da kann man hoch.
Ich habe das auch noch nie gesehen, dass man da hoch kann.
Aber anscheinend macht er das gerne hier.
Aim ist das Regel. Vielleicht. Keine Ahnung.
Ich lade dich gleich mal ein für eine Runde Wasser.
Das wird lustig.
Mal gucken, ob die dann mit echtem Trollen besser spielt.
Down.
Wo ist der andere? Der andere ist in der Mitte.
Hüft.
Aber mit der kannst du auch aus der Hüfte schießen.
Damit triffst du alles.
Naja, das war Glück.
Farmers, das ist die beste.
Ist das Burst? Ist das Burst?
Einer ist hier mitte oben.
Rechts von dir.
Fuck, Alter.
Ziel, bitte. Dann driffst du dir auf.
Das macht dich so viel besser.
Wenn du nämlich anfängst zu zielen, dann driffst du nämlich alles.
Easy, Chat.
Genau, Chat. Easy clap.
Wir brauchen noch einmal Energie.
Einer ist oben.
Ich habe keine Chance, wenn er so piept.
Deswegen will ich ihn auch nicht mehr piepen.
Gib mir jetzt die Nade.
Einer ist rechts am Start.
Ich hör links was laufen.
Rechts zur Seite.
Ey, was geht ab?
Wie?
Da war links hinten, als er mich gekillt hat.
Also...
Ja.
Ich habe mehr HP.
Nice.
Reaktion 1,0.
Ich schreibe mich gerade, was bei denen abgeht.
Was ist das?
Hot Nugget.
Ja.
Racer ist durchgeproscht.
Nein.
Ich habe nur HP. Oder nicht?
Doch.
Oben.
Er hat einen Schuss schon.
Er ist bei der Treppe.
Hat 55.
Links, links, links.
Durchs Geländer.
Der ist halt in den Kopf gegangen, weil er dich getroffen hat und du Aimpunch hattest.
Aber der hatte schon Damage von dir.
Wahrscheinlich wäre er auch so gestorben.
Der ist einfach hinten im Spawn drin oben.
Der.
Ich brenne.
Ich habe nur noch 20 HP.
Der eine ist immer noch im Spawn hinten.
Ich mag dieses Hot Nugget einfach absolut nicht.
Ich mag es nicht.
What the fuck? Du triffst...
Sind die beide da hinten?
Nimm mal auf die Flagge einfach. Versuch es.
Der eine steht in der Flagge.
Das ist aber eine Kackpistole.
Die Deagle ist einfach verunstaltet worden.
Das ist der Single Schuss.
Dazu noch eine Deagle mit Autismus.
Deine ist hier runtergegriffen.
Der piekt in der Mitte.
Marvin.
Den linken. Den links ist auch noch einer.
Der ist der Letzte.
Ich habe ihn getroffen mit dem Termit.
Er kommt hier rechts außen.
Er hat schon einen Hit.
Wie machen die das mit der Deagle?
20 HP.
Er kann schneller schießen mit der Deagle.
Er kann viel schneller schießen als du.
Aber easy.
Ins Fuß geschossen.
Das Fuß.
Oder eigentlich zwischen die Füße.
Zum Glück hat er schon einen Hit drin.
Jetzt müssen wir.
Das ist wieder das gleiche.
Ich bin rechts drauf.
Ich glaube, die sind beide rechts.
Ich glaube.
Ich glaube so.
Einer Down.
Der eine ist noch oben.
Er hat einen Hit.
Einfach schießen auf Mausrad?
Das geht?
Sagt der Chat gerade.
Ja, das geht.
You know what, you lost to STFU.
Sind sie am Flamen?
Bitte beherrsch dich.
Deine Mutter mag das auch nicht.
Deswegen habe ich Voice Chat aus.
Er sagt, du deutsche Wurensohn.
Solche Wortfolge.
Anzeige ist aber aus.
Aber ohne Witz.
Aber die wird immer abgelehnt.
Aber schießen auf Mausrad?
Wie wird man den Maus gescheit bewegen?
Das ist ein Gunfight.
Ach, die spielt echt Gunfight.
Aber spielt die mit jemanden zusammen?
Okay.
Wir raiden dich jetzt.
Ich lade jetzt meine Kollegen ein.
Dann stehen wir gleich vor uns.
Also Chat.
Focus.
Max muss jetzt ins Bett.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
Wir sind noch jung und frisch.
Genau.
Dann haue noch ein paar Wins raus.
Bis dann.
Ich mache Discord aus.
Bis dann. Tschüss.
Also Chat, wir raiden ihn jetzt mal.
War echt ganz schönes Geschwitze am Schluss.
Was willst du machen?
Wir sehen uns. Macht es gut.
Tschüss.